[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
she's back again with another podcast
good evening and hi and welcome to
Auntie Jenny's video channel to Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
okay okay then then get out then get out
faster Esther then get out I'm not here
to get canceled today most men want a
woman that has some degree of femininity
where they feel like they're taking care
of taking care of and lady like I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened to society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
cookies
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
seriously seriously though like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams
um okay so a couple announcements before
we start the show
um
first of all uh we have four membership
tiers if you want to be a part of the
live chat today how many likes do we
need to open up the chat
uh thousand thousand five hundred likes
to open up the chat today
um but otherwise the first tier gets you
to be a part of the chat that is the
five dollar tier second tier you get our
Discord behind the scenes Vlogs third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and the fourth tiers and
one-on-one call with me once a month you
know I got 1.5 million subscribers in a
year so if you want to learn how to do
that I would sign up for that call we
can go over your thumbnails titles and
just overall YouTube strategy
also guys um they took away my first
Instagram so go follow my second one
just probably things one they also
banned me five times on Tick Tock so go
follow my Tick Tock just pearly things
they gave me my original username back
which was very exciting um
also subscribe to wife school I'm doing
a dancing episode this weekend so if you
want to see me try to dance I'm really
bad so it'll probably probably be very
entertaining for you guys
um and I think that's pretty much it
um so
welcome to the show guys
um why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself I'm
starting here and then go around
my name is Taz
I am 34 years old
um I have a beautiful lady she's amazing
and
um
I mean
yeah I play Ice Hockey
that's it that's me
cool
um I'm trying really hard to think of a
fun fact
um it doesn't it could just be it could
just be a stat you know it doesn't even
have to be that's true I mean I cosplay
that's pretty weird
um I'm pretty nerdy um like yeah I'm
pretty it's strange on the internet that
is my job um my name is Kelly Jean and I
forgot what the other things are
supposed to do your name age
relationship status fun fact well I am
single and I don't have my real age out
there because people are stalky and
creepy but I told these guys my age okay
I could give you an age range okay yeah
sure go ahead all right between 25 and
35. okay okay cool go ahead what's up
I'm TR Michelle I'm 34.
and fun fact I do music
I make UK r b hip-hop UK trap soul
uh my relationship statuses I'm
will you saying you can hear me now yeah
okay I'm tr mashiel day four
I do music UK r b hip-hop better UK trap
soul
and I'm taken take it
hi guys I'm mecom21
um relationship status I'm single and uh
fun fact
um I shoot guns in my free time I'm a
competitive shooter so yeah
hi my name's Jenny
um Jennifer
cool
um I'm 25 I am single and fun fact I was
born in Germany oh cool yeah it's broken
Deutsch ambition no no
I lived in Germany for a couple months I
was like maybe just when I was younger
um okay so today's topic was inspired
because this weekend I went to a
volleyball tournament and I went and I
noticed there was a lot of trans people
playing in the tournament and so that's
something I've never really seen before
so today's topic we're going to talk
about
to start trans women and men in sports
and vice versa
um so what are you guys's opinions on
trans people playing in sports of the
opposite or like trans women playing in
women's sports go ahead
I feel like it's something that cannot
be generalized
I feel like every sport is different
every
um
yeah every sport has a different skill
set every sport has different levels of
contact
UM different different aspects that you
need that could either benefit or not be
benefited by the use of like hormones so
I think
I think personally it's it's something
it's something that can't be generalized
and it's something that has to be seen
as like a sort of like subject by
subject situation or metal okay would
you what about for volleyball that's the
example I used
volleyball
see I mean it depends on how much length
you want to go into I mean I don't know
volleyball to a certain extent I can
imagine that you know if if for example
you've got um someone who is female to
male and they're taking testosterone
they're playing with
um like CIS women you could you could
come you could comment on the fact that
testosterone allows like
um like muscle muscle build quicker or
like you know therefore they might get
like a harder a harder Spike for example
but then I know some insanely strong CIS
women so does that really take things
like into another dimension in the game
I don't know to be honest
so it I don't think there's been enough
research or enough
um
yeah I don't I don't think there's been
enough of a look into it today okay so
for the time being what do you think
they should do should we integrate or
should we keep them separate well as far
as volleyball goes yeah volleyball
women's and men's sports in general
again I can't I can't say okay you don't
know your answer could be I don't know
yeah okay my idea in my opinion
go ahead you're okay well the problem is
I can talk a lot and I don't want to
hike drown these guys out but I can go
now if you want yeah should I let the
others speak I don't know because I can
talk for a lot
it's up to you you know either go or
don't go
so I almost have a similar opinion to
you it does depend on the sport and the
governing body
um but there are a number of things that
I would do probably differently because
testosterone isn't the only thing we
should be taking into account depending
on the sport especially because there
are a number of differences between men
and women that aren't changed just by
taking hormones
um for example men have more type 2
muscle fibers and women have more type 1
type 2 is more for bursts of strength
and type one is for endurance so women
are better in endurance and are better
at like running really fast so an
obvious example of where I think it may
end up being unfair would maybe be with
sprinting
but the longer the distance the running
the more fair it becomes
with volleyball volleyball is really
difficult and I played a lot of team
sports when I was a kid not volleyball I
played netball which is the girl bad
version of basketball and rounders which
is the bad girl version of
um
baseball base is really English
bad Sports they kind of suck I don't
know why they make us do those but I
will say
so assuming we're talking like at school
level so like before anyone's really had
time to transition or do much I played
with boys in rounders and it was not fun
they hit the ball for like 10 times
further and then I'm out there and like
the depth of field running after the
damn balls for like most of the game so
I will say like
there are issues with it
um it kind of Defense at what level
which game and how you're integrating
people
I am an advocate for not throwing the
baby out with a bath water so I think it
can work
but I don't know if it's working right
now
okay then yeah what do you think
yeah I mean I think that they should
just be able to play to be honest I mean
even with people who are born a certain
way there's people that are better at
doing things than others that's just how
it goes I mean I understand that
uh mainly for men who transition into
women
I think I understand what they're saying
sometimes for example you know if it was
to say like boxing
you know um a person who was born a man
and then transitioned into a woman maybe
later on in life fully developed into
puberty and then decides to get into a
ring with a woman who was born a woman
I think that might be a bit techy but
I think the whole point of transitioning
is to be who you feel you are and if
you've got an interest in if you have an
interest and a passion in sport
I don't think you shouldn't be allowed
to play that sport
because you've decided to transition I
understand
how it can be unfair phys with
physically but it comes with it you know
it comes with it I think so I just think
that what do you think because I just
don't think it's fair
um even if we just take things like
height like I'm in the top one percent
of hype for females and I was like short
when it came to getting recruited for
colleges like if we brought men in there
I'd be in the top 15 and like I really
wouldn't have any opportunity if men
were you know even if it's like trans
women like after they transition the
height stays the same yeah I think
usually like for example with my
previous example with boxing there's
usually like weight classes so with
boxing it's probably like yeah a little
bit okay because you'd be much fairly
but um like you said about
um running
I don't I'm not too sure I don't know
that information about
um I think you said sorry what did you
say that I'm sprinting T1 and T2 or
something yeah twitch muscle fibers so
men and women tend to have a different
percentage of both but we don't right
because why do men win in marathons then
um so when I say endurance I'm talking
like Ultra endurance is where men and
women tend to be well they compete
together and women win often like it's
about 50 50 who's winning but Ultra it
looks like a very Fringe small it's not
Fringe but it is crazy because I mean
when you're doing these types of ultra
endurance swimming there's a decent
chance of death like somebody just died
recently trying to swim the channel
Crossing
yeah I mean it's difficult that I think
it's Manhattan Island swimming and it's
a British Isle alone right but my point
is in general matter faster definitely
faster so if you as I said sprinting
that counts for short distance well but
even with marathons men are still faster
I mean there might be like a fringe
ultra marathon but that's like Ultra
endurance is definitely longer than a
regular Marathon yeah right but I'm
saying more people compete in a marathon
and you said it's still 50 50 for Ultra
and I just can't imagine that's that
popular of a sport like it's very hard
obviously a lot of people don't want to
do it because it's so difficult it is
yeah clearly I could I did a marathon as
the worst day of my life
my mom was a long distance Runner yeah
it's uh it's a tough one
um but it just becomes so men would have
the disadvantage because they don't have
the same muscle fibers as women so when
they transition they don't have the
advantage within that endurance
necessarily and assuming that there is
some negative impact to certain things
when they're taking estrogenism somewhat
I think it's fine for Endurance Sports
so what about what about marathons you'd
make it
um so there are a number of sports there
are some where I'm sure it's fine there
are some where I'm fairly sure it's not
fine and then there's some in the Middle
where I think we need more research done
like I'm not gonna say no or yes to the
ones in the middle because
um I'm not sure I do think that we need
to study more less just reduction of
testosterone and more of the other
things that make men you know stronger
in various ways like lung capacity and
height to a point so oh it's it's super
important yeah because I played
basketball and volleyball it's super
important for volleyball and basketballs
it is super important but there's a
bunch of sports where High either
doesn't matter or being shorter is
actually beneficial so that's why I say
it does depend on sport but I think for
the sports where height does matter it
is important to it might just be that
we have to cap trans women like you can
compete but only if you're under the
height of the tallest woman that can
compete right because then you're not
like full five inches taller than they
are or something it's it's hard and I I
can appreciate that you're in a
difficult position with that
yeah but even if they're the same height
it's like they're stronger than us
it's really difficult like
how many people are there on a
volleyball six six five for basketball
yeah so it's like quite impactful if he
has yeah
team sports so the thing that I have the
least amount of um experience with too
so I don't want to speak well my my
thing is like if we're gonna title at
women's sports and men's sports I think
it's like misleading if we go to a
tournament expecting it to be women and
then there's there's trans people there
you know like because because then it's
like I didn't agree to that like I
agreed to to play in the win like
because that's why I was pissed off this
weekend because it was like these like
one one of the teams we just set the
trans trans woman every single time and
it's like and one other team had had
four or five and I'm like I just don't
think that's really clear yeah yeah
Philippines in Brazil it was called All
Nations so it's like from different
Philippines and Brazil much just yeah it
must be big there those are those two I
always got the impression that it wasn't
really enough transgender people to have
their own sort of sports so I will
hypothesize how I would temporarily fix
this situation later because I don't
want to ramble too much and let everyone
because these guys haven't really spoken
yet
you see you're an athlete so you've
actually played so you actively you can
have an opinion because you're in that
situation so
personally my opinion
is is that it's kind of it's just really
a struggle I feel for like a female
athlete you're going now obviously you
just mentioned that you go there and
it's like for transgender players on
your opposing side and it's like you do
do you feel uncomfortable do you feel
like oh you know I might not be able to
be you know like you're not comparable
biologically generally because like
there's a difference no I I don't think
it's comparable I mean I I've played
with men so like I've played like um Co
like basketball like you always play at
parks so I've played pick up but I know
if I play I played basketball for maybe
16 years and I know if I go against a
guy who's played maybe five to seven
he'll be me like easy
yeah I think it's like I personally feel
like if there are like you're saying I
mean there's like four transgender
people on the other side
I feel like then you should just have
volleyball specifically just for
transgender people because then that
would make more sense right
it's just it's just not I feel like it's
not fair it's just not fair you know
um there's too many exceptions and then
when there's too many exceptions it just
gets messy so it should really be
straightforward you know this is
volleyball for transgender people you
know do you think there should be a
third League there definitely should be
one okay what do you think yeah I agree
with
um
the lady here
um I think there should be a whole
separate league for you guys because
um
thinking of the people that are coming
to watch it right their mindsets are
like
if it's just women playing this should
be just women playing right and they're
coming to support their women that are
playing right so I just feel like maybe
if they had their own league with their
own supporters it kind of works out what
Change Is Gonna Come at some point where
we are going to integrate both all three
genders right I hope not oh you never
know oh gosh times times are changing so
no no if I went up against a six seven
dude I would never get to play
you know because it like I understand
because I know a lot of the argument is
like well I'm tall like I'd be taller
than a lot of you know people that are
trans transitioned or whatever but I I
think the issue that I get into is like
there's still the top percentage are
going to be taller than the top
percentage of women yeah do you know if
those that that four-person team they
were all taller than you or did you meet
them or yeah
um some were taller some were shorter
like one was um a libero but even you
could just tell like when they were
playing like they're just more like
volleyball is a really technical sport
right so you have to train for like
I don't know I I would say like five
years before you really even get good
volley rallies going but like men can
kind of just do it off the cuff because
they're just so much straw it's hard to
explain unless you know the sport I can
imagine that there is an advantage with
being told over because of the height of
the net right it's gonna be easier to
you know even in the background just
it's so weird guys can do these just
like crazy ups that women just it takes
us so much longer to get there did you
find the same disadvantage even with the
shoulder players yes and it was strength
so they hit harder
um I would say they were just a bit
quick you can just tell I I can't really
describe what it was you could just tell
the difference like they're a little bit
quicker a little bit more agile like
they could just do things that the women
couldn't
okay
um so you guys you you think it's it
depends on the sport right so what would
you say do you think there are certain
sports that trans people should be
banned from would you agree with that
it's hard because say for example you
take a
I don't know you take a trans woman
okay
they
I don't know I don't to be honest I
don't know the process but like if you
had a trans woman who had been taking
puberty blockers from Young
um therefore did not necessarily go
through puberty
um as like a CIS man
um who then started taking hormone
therapy to develop as a female
and therefore has no
hormonal
um
advantage and so I don't know how many
hours they've been I don't know how much
they've worked out I don't know all this
but if they are on the same sort of
hormonal level
if that would make a difference if that
would give them an advantage or if that
would be them on a Level Playing Field
with someone like you and I don't know
so
I do think that there are certain Sports
where it is a little bit dangerous and
sometimes it can be
um
irresponsible to put someone in a
situation for example like you said
boxing or like a combat sport if someone
like for example if they got to a
certain age
um where they've been through puberty
they've been in the gym you know they
they trained as a boxer as like a CIS
man
for years and years and then decided to
transition and enter into women's league
I think that might be slightly
irresponsible like the the level of
strength and power that that person has
over a CIS female might be insane but
then like I said before I know some
insanely strong CIS females so
again I can't give you a definitive
answer I can't say whether or not I
think it's good or bad I do think that
Sports has an insanely positive
um
uh like repercussion on on on on the
person who takes part in it like you as
a sports person I can imagine that's
your movie meditation when I play Ice
Hockey that's my move in meditation
nothing outside the ice rink matters
it's like everything that's going crazy
in my head just goes into this beautiful
filing cabinet and it it everything just
makes sense for a while and
so to to take that away from someone who
is merely trying to live the life that
they feel is right for them who is not
hurting anyone who's not going out of
their way to to cause malice or anything
like that I think
that's high but but I think it does hurt
people because it hurts like it's kind
of like if I train for 16 years just to
have opportunity taken and given to
someone that I would say has an
advantage like I don't think there's any
amount of drugs that you can make it
equal because I think I think at the end
of the day like you still are what
you're born 100 and it's it's it is
always going to be a hard situation and
I do think it's always going to be
something that should be seen Case by
case because it also you know there's so
many things that that go into it it's
the person's mentality you know like you
know if you're going something like
boxing are you just trying to score
points are you trying to be malicious
phone Boxers usually get to like pick
who they're fighting
I think I think the issue was there was
a case a couple years ago where they
didn't it was um someone didn't describe
I could be wrong but I think they didn't
disclose they were trans
I don't know and then someone got hurt
I'm pretty sure the only one I know they
did know she was trans but
I don't know yeah I just think if you
sign up for it yeah yeah go ahead
because there were girls out there who
are crazy enough to be like hell yeah
they like the competition I mean I will
say there is one benefit to I won't say
training with men because it's training
with trans women but but let's just say
both but if they have an advantage is it
does push you to be better because you
know you've got that competition to
compete with
but with team sports is really
um complicated because it's not just one
person versus one person it's not just
you know like I don't know swimming
where it's everyone's running on a line
or what's swimming in a line it's a
little more complicated when it's team
sports what did you guys think of late
Leah Thomas
did you guys agree with that I think
that the way that they dealt with Leah
Thomas was really bad because
so that she won fifth place right joint
with another girl and then they said
we're going to give the trophy to the
Leah Thomas and I'm like do you think
Leah Thomas should have been allowed to
swim though
um under the rules that they put in she
didn't do anything wrong
no matter your personal
so I mean she was quite significantly
bigger than the rest of them right and
lung capacity is actually really
important with swimming
um I don't know how high is much but
sometimes
I I mean
and I need a yes or no she only came
fifth right though no they she won the
difference yeah there was more than one
event I only heard more about the person
like because the other person didn't
even get to hold the trophy because they
said Leah Thomas is gonna get it and I'm
like that's really cool because my my
issue is with it is again it's like we
we train especially in women's sports we
train so long and there's no money in it
there's like no money at the end of it
so it's like you train your whole life
for a couple opportunities that you get
and so she trained I like and especially
just like as an athlete I know how long
we like look forward to our senior year
of college like that's like you've
trained your whole life this is the best
you're gonna be you're probably not
gonna play after this she gets that
moment and it it's taken from her if I'm
being honest because I just don't think
it's fair I mean I can hypothesize now
how I would fix these situations at
least temporarily from the meantime with
something like swimming it's really easy
right so you simply just have additional
trophies and then you give them one for
whatever number that they represent but
the CIS women aren't losing out so if
there are say it's a qualifier there are
20 places but one of them goes to a
trans woman just let the 21st Place go
in as well now I just I just don't think
we should be forced to compete with them
like even even if it's an individual
sport that way no one's really losing
out right if we have additional trophies
we can say CIS women first second third
if um Leah Thomas comes but then we have
to make all these exceptions like I just
I just think it gets confusing and I
just think we should stick it to
biological biological women probably
assume can I make a point like is it
really a competition if everyone's a
winner um
I mean that's not everyone's a winner
they were the only place if they match
the time or come in between of the time
of a CIS woman so it wouldn't be like
it's better than what is now right it
would be better than us now because
otherwise the trans woman would simply
just take the place that won't be an
additional place for us this woman
let me ask I'm looking at compromises
rather than saying yeah yeah I'm just
trying my best so what about form I'm
just I'm just interested in if the same
worry and concern would apply for
transgender people who have gone from
female to male because then it would be
surely on the on the basis of your
philosophy it will be a disadvantage for
the trans man
you know and I think that I just think
it should be fair because you know like
if a trans man was to go against a CIS
man I'm bearing in mind the trans man
has again transitioned late in his life
and has gone through female puberty yeah
I don't know if they're gonna be at the
same level as a CIS man does it mean
that they can't participate
no I I think it should be biological man
biological women I think that's how we
should we should slip flip it but I I
don't think
okay and and you can't take drugs
obviously to be in the women's league I
think it just has to be on biology I
mean they can participate but they'll
lose
okay it depends right okay so because I
can speak about gymnastics I don't think
it depends on
so with gymnastics you have an advantage
if you're shorter you can do more
rotations obviously more women tend to
be shorter than men
I've seen the flips I've seen the flips
yeah
I know no she she's very good but I'm
saying the men like they go higher when
they when they jump off the no so like
with gymnastics it's not just being
shorter that's beneficial but it depends
on the discipline I will say there are
some disciplines within gymnastics a
trans man would not have fun with like
rings for example is all about upper
body strength ew that's gonna suck but
when it comes to like floor exercise
um
um and also I I see it the other way
around as well a trans woman would not
have an advantage because she's going to
be taller for example when you're doing
beam having smaller feet is an advantage
and being shorter men struggle on the
beam that's why they don't do it as a
thing like men and women's gymnastics is
pretty different there's only like a
couple of shared disciplines within the
two
which is Vault and floor
um the bars are very different for both
because they're adapted so like
flexibility is the biggest one in
gymnastics and women are more flexible
than men so if being shorter is a
benefit and being more flexible is a
benefit then it makes sense maybe maybe
there's specific things in gymnastics
but I still think biological men
biological women to avoid all this
confusion because by that logic then the
women would go into the men's league and
then they would be at an advantage I I
my guy is telling me my God's telling me
the guys would still win but but you
know I could be I don't know gymnastics
that's quite different in gymnastic
would you say that the sportswear both
men and women have like the same like
disciplines would you say the women are
more athletic or better gymnasts than
the guys I think women are better at
floor there's a reason why female
gymnastics has the highest viewership in
the Olympics I don't think I don't think
it's because of these I think
is more
um is more is a better gymnast at the
best male gymnast so because the
gymnastics is about flexibility rather
than just pure strength except for Rings
potentially
um to an extent yeah like gymnastics is
not about flexibility flexibility is
something you need to do gymnastic
gymnastics is about pulling off
um skillful
so like flexibility and so if you're
short which women tend to be shorter
than men on average you're able to do
more rotations on four exercises than
you are as a man
you just listed a couple with less you
said Rings yeah Rings trans men would
probably yeah but the whole the whole
point doesn't even really matter because
if you're saying women have the
advantage then then it would just be
vice versa so I'm saying to avoid the
confusion it should just be biological
men biological women I understand it
like it feels good to simplify things
that way and I it's not necessarily a
wrong opinion to have
um I I will say like although trans
women are a protected class and you know
I'm pro-trans I'm not anti-transit
anyway at all
so are women women are a protected class
and that becomes an issue when it seems
like both sides are complaining about
their hurt feelings so for me I wanna
wait what do you mean what do you mean
hurt feelings well because I would say
from The Athlete's side we're not
complaining about our hurt feelings we
don't want to get hurt so the two main
complaints are both sides saying I'm
uncomfortable for one reason or another
and I'm like I don't care if you're
uncomfortable for either side it's it's
irrelevant to how we're going to fix the
issue
um and the other issue is like
acceptance that is being
forced to a point where I think that to
be fair I think trans women have been
told a lie which is simply that reducing
your testosterone just fixes everything
magically and I think they believe it
um because they've been told it and who
wouldn't really believe things that
they've been told and if certain
governing bodies every governing body in
sports is different right so not every
governing body allows X Y or Z is
variable
um
but I do think that it's the governing
bodies and the sports themselves that
kind of let this situation get to the
point of where it is like I don't have
any ill will towards the trans people in
this discussion it's not really their
fault it's fun yeah but it's not about
ill but we're just talking about
policies so it's not about what should
you do it's like what would the policies
be should they be allowed and if well so
and so I'm a proposal the same as him
I'm like it's variable I understand so
it's yeah it depends on the sport okay
um
what's the next one because you said
something about
what about locker rooms bathrooms they
need their own unit they need their own
space because
I've from just watching like I've
watched um
basically you know there's there was an
episode on Glee when the student unique
went into the female's bathroom right
and then as he came out well as he came
out of the the stall
um one of the cheerleaders stopped him
and was like you can't use this bathroom
you're not allowed you're a man and from
that it triggered a whole situation
within the school where people where
boys were walking into girls locker
rooms and girls are walking into male
locker rooms and it just made the whole
thing a confusing space for people not
until the end of the show I watched
right and where they gave them his own
key to his own cubicle and it just
everything went back to normal so I just
feel as if they need their own space if
that makes sense their own unit their
own bathroom so they don't feel like
they have to be pressured to go into the
boys bathroom or to the girls bathroom
depending on what I mean I don't like to
get naked in front of anyone so I've
never have to because luckily I guess
with my schools and with whatever gyms
and swimming pools I've been to they've
always had like private cubicles but I
feel like shared ones is more common in
the US I think well in an Athletics but
even at the tournament this weekend they
were in there
okay I feel like that's uncomfortable
for everyone right I was just like no no
you're pretty you you get as an athlete
you get pretty comfortable changing in
front of women I hate it but that's just
women yeah that's not what I'm saying
these women if it was trans women I'd
feel like okay
okay you as once a man okay I will start
to think a little bit like are you
watching me sort of thing I'm just a
person it's uncomfortable
for both like it's uncomfortable for
trans women and for women because I can
like me putting myself in a trans
woman's shoes which I I can I can try I
mean I can't exactly relate but
I would feel very
just I would have so many like a million
doubts and thoughts running in my head
like I think having a changing room just
dedicated to trans people would be so
much better for them and for everyone
else
I think we should just private cubicles
for all yeah
you know because I even know the
bathroom like I don't I just want like I
just think even when you're doing your
makeup and you're just doing like girl
stuff I don't know it's just nice to
just have girls in there it's something
if I can just it sounded like a little
bit um
it's the right word like Prejudice
because you know if someone's
transitioned
then they've they should be able to go
into the
um restroom of that gender that they
trans translating bathrooms no I think
it's a bit crazy because let's just say
for example you have a trans woman or a
trans man that now goes into the
restroom of the gender that they was
born
but they've already started surgeries
they've already started testosterone
they're gonna be majorly misplaced and
anyone that's in that restaurant with
them is gonna feel super uncomfortable I
mean if they've completed their
transition or even halfway through it
then transition
then and no no one would know the
difference especially if for example no
you can you can tell not all the time
maybe with men to female sometimes
because of for example like height hand
size feet size but not every single man
is like six foot some men are small I'm
also like Rich lesbians kind of get the
worst of this because there's a lot more
like masculine lesbians and there are
like trans women that I've ever met in
the wild because I have trans friends
but I I don't think I've ever met one
just even even when we go to like locker
rooms like if you if you in public you
you get naked that's indecent exposure
and so but it's like especially a lot of
the trans
um women like they don't end up getting
the surgeries
or trans yeah they don't end up getting
the surgery so it's like I I don't want
the thing is I think because they always
use Blair white as an example like
that's always the one that like Destiny
always throw at us but it's like he
didn't get the surgery I'm not too sure
who that is but like you know like we we
say that obviously gender and sexuality
are two different things no I don't
think so but they are though because you
have you have lesbian women and gay men
and they would never dream of
transitioning they're happy as men oh
sexually happy to be getting happy to be
gay men and you know those women are
happy to be gay women they've got no
intentions of transitioning but if
someone has transitions because equally
people transition
and are still attracted sexually to
the other sex if I'm making sense so for
example you could be born female
transition into a man
and then be attracted to men
so then you'd be a gay trans man
yeah so what I'm saying is I don't even
really care about the sections the
biology I hear you but to make my point
if you're a transgender person who has
transitioned and isn't gay in that
transition I don't see how you can
possibly make anyone in a restroom feel
uncomfortable so if you're a trans man
and you like women you go into a men's
locker room as a man who lacks women
you're not posing any threat to any of
those men in that locker room you're not
perving on anyone and equally the same
if you're a a a man born a man who then
trans transitions into a woman and finds
men sexually attractive you're not gonna
go into the locker room and stop would
you would you agree that the
transition's mental
I think it has to start off mental 100
it has to start but you would agree you
can't actually be the other gender no
you can get surgeries to make you so to
make you look like it but you you
wouldn't actually like no yes you can be
you can't change your DNA you can't
change you can't change you can't change
your DNA no you can't change your DNA
you can like actually change your gender
well you can change your body you can
change the show I mean the way it looks
right yeah I mean I'm a spiritual person
so for me this body right here is just
my show now if some if an accident
happened to me God forbid and I was
paralyzed that doesn't make me less of
anything because I can't use my body our
body is just our body who we are inside
right so so it's mental though it's not
physical it's mental and emotional and
then it can and then if it's strong
enough you'll change the physical to
match the mentality you can't like you
can't you know like uh a man like a
trans man can't get a woman pregnant and
vice versa
can't get a woman pregnant how many CIS
women are there.com I don't think it's I
just wouldn't say I would say it's a
false equivalency no because it sounds
like there's no point though they're
still built the way they're built right
like they still were born with those
parts there's a woman who can't get
pregnant and actually like a CIS woman
who can't get pregnant isn't less of a
woman because she can't get pregnant
exactly the same way a man is not less
of a man because he quite impregnated
exactly right but they're but they're
still a woman because they're born a
woman yes yes right yeah and so my point
my point is it's mental it's not
physical it starts off mental and even
even I've seen I've seen pictures of
like on Twitter I did not want to it's
just you ever been on Twitter and like
of like the surgeries it doesn't look
the same well the thing is yeah it
doesn't and the thing is yeah like it's
not gonna be able to look the same do
you understand like this it's just how
it goes you know if a white person was
to want to get a skin as a tan they're
not gonna look black you know I mean
like there's certain things if a black
person wants to let get light like and
they start bleaching you can tell they
were getting better with it too you just
have to let people be who they are like
all of this judgment and oh yeah but you
don't look you don't let people live
their truth
and I don't care I don't care if you
live your truth like but like and do you
like do what you want to your body but
to me it's just like I think that women
have the right to our own spaces like I
think we have the right people I think
we no I don't think the race thing
really isn't equivalent but I think like
women have the right to our own spaces
I agree I agree I agree with I fully
agree with what you're saying and I
understand you know the difficulties
with women who are playing sports with
trans men but I think that the
difficulties that you women sister well
even in bathrooms too I would say the
same thing because at the at the end of
the day you know they they still need to
be honest I've gone into men's bathrooms
quite a lot because they have short cues
so I don't I don't know it's like that's
like a female privilege isn't it the
other way around I hate them so much
society that has really started to over
sexualize people like I didn't I don't
know about Europe but when I go to the
toilet like I literally go in there to
go to the toilet that's it I go in the
toilet I come out I wash my hands and I
walk out trying to say unless it's not
the trans woman is doing something
legitimately weird like staring or they
have like a hard-on or something bad
they probably are just changing and it's
just awkward for everyone involved but I
I don't know like I just I'm awkward
around everyone I wanted to add
something to the conversation so I have
a daughter I I think you guys are
focusing too much on the people that are
adults no not even that I think you guys
are focusing too much on the people that
like the people that are going through
this and their feelings what you're
feeling to realize is that we're talking
about the policies so the policies make
it possible for a man to transition into
the woman and go into a female boss
bathroom so if the policies make that
possible you're forgetting that we have
people that are criminals we have people
that are off there that are crazy that
will take advantage of those kind of
policies
my point is
if those policies exist
people that can take advantage of those
policies will take advantage there's
literally nothing to stop anyone from
going into anybody you know yes
stand outside of the background there's
nothing to stop anyone there's not to
stop anyone but the mere fact that you
you're you're basically disregarding
social can gay men not allow are gay men
not allowed to use men's bathroom in
case men that are not gay are worried
that the gay men entering are gonna have
perv on them are lesbians not allowed to
use
this I think that's a false equivalent
okay so what's the problem the reason
why I say this way is because when you
argue from the men's side men don't care
because the reality of a man's world is
we have to defend ourselves in whatever
situation anyways right so the
protection is actually for the women I
don't care if a woman comes into my
bathroom because I know she's she can't
do like there's very little she can do
right right so it's actually unless
she's got a weapon exactly right but
it's actually more for the women so my
point is if I have a daughter I don't
want a situation where policies allow
someone to be able to go into the
bathroom to perform her but can I ask a
question what didn't it be this is what
I was saying before about sexuality if a
trans woman okay has gone into a woman's
bathroom and she is heterosexual now
and she loves men is that not less pervy
than a gay going into today
with the women
start putting labels on their head about
who they don't just have to just just do
yourself just do your thing yeah and if
someone if you feel like someone at this
point but his point is we we won't know
but we can see with Jan you can't know
you can't know sexuality you don't know
no I don't remember we're not talking
about sexuality we're talking about
gender
regardless like if a predator wants to
predict a predator will predate it's
that simple like if someone has that in
their mind and that's what they want to
do they will and they will have done
that for years and years but but you're
making it easy not necessarily and it's
like it just makes me uncomfortable like
I don't want to change I don't want to
go to the bathroom like in in front of
guys and and you can you know you can
dress like a woman act like a woman it
doesn't make you a woman well it does
though that's the thing if they don't
have a penis anymore you know what I
mean then I mean they don't even know
but they don't have ovaries and even
when you were talking earlier about
women sorry to cut you the I mean it's a
very very small percentage
um and and they were still like they're
supposed to have ovaries it's very
different than chopping your off
and I hear you like the thing is I hear
your concern and I'm sure a lot of
people have the same concerns as you but
what I'm trying to get you to understand
is somehow in some way as much as you
have your opinion it is a little bit
prejudiced you know and and I get that
your Prejudice may come from yeah
it's still prejudice and I think that
you know you have to understand that
when you've got these viewpoints yeah
sometimes it's hypocritical because and
that's why I'm using sexuality that's
why I'm saying there's probably women in
your bathroom that are checking you out
if they're gay if they're lesbians so
for you lesbians can be pretty
aggressive
you to dismiss them and then jump On
trance but there's no pilot but there's
no policy that we can push that like you
can't do that because there's again he
was saying there's no sign on their head
saying that they're gay and they don't
have to they don't have to and I'm not
the same thing
yeah but it is so obvious
men that become women it's so obvious
you can tell noise
no but when you say not always that's
like a very small percentage I think the
vast majority you can because of the
access to care no it's so the access to
surgery how many people like trans
people have you guys but not everyone
has access to surgery it's so expensive
exactly it's so expensive well and then
the point is make somebody acceptably
transfer for society they have to go
through all these surgeries is that what
you're saying it's not it's crazy I'm
not saying I'm not I'm saying by
identifying I'm not talking about no I
mean I just don't think it was one but
if they're stealth then they can go into
the toilet right so if you don't if you
don't realize that they're it's not
about stuff I just don't think it's like
because you're not you're not on edge
because they don't have an Adam's apple
no I just I just think it's like why do
I have to agree to the delusion like
you're not it doesn't make you the
opposite gender because you dress like
it and get something some people aren't
necessarily even trying to access that
they're not even trying to be cisgender
some people are not trying to be like
their CIS counterparts some people are
just trying to make the outside match
the inside and that doesn't necessarily
mean that they will claim that they are
cisgender it doesn't it doesn't mean
that they want to necessarily be
cisgender it just means that they
actually feels mad uncomfortable with a
bit they feel mad uncomfortable with the
fact that they've got you know leg hair
they've got they're uncomfortable with
their genitalia and they don't like it
then it doesn't match them but then if
they decide to to to alter the outside
or to start you know changing how they
look and making themselves feel pretty
the way that they feel that they should
and they can't go into a man's toilet
safely I don't want to steal Man Pearl a
little bit because
I I want to say the majority of trans
women don't think this is women but
there are some people that are
delusional and do push it to a point so
it's like you can't just but I'm saying
it's like everybody
right but I'm saying when when you're
forcing us to accept them as women and
treat them as women then it's like
you're forcing me to live in the
delusion when I can see you're clearly
not so like when I'm forced to play with
them now I have to you know and I don't
even get a choice in this like now I
have to succumb to their definitions but
even even in the locker room because I
go into the locker room now I have to
now I have to pretend that they're
supposed to be there now I have to go to
the bathrooms and pretend people have
been pretending like trans people don't
exist where I didn't say they don't they
clearly people are part of society for
for like
but the issue we get to is that if we
don't if we don't give a hard line then
later there will be consequences and
that's what you see with the with the um
the men going into female prisons and
they and they get raped there was a
couple cases in California that just
happened and we've already so in England
we've already prepped for that so we
have a transgender weighing too but we
have the same problem we did have a
transgender woman rape a woman because
that was really stupid because she
wasn't like she wasn't post-op or
anything it was really dumb I I feel
like there's some situations but people
just turn their brain but my problem is
like if like that's why I just think we
make it simple biological men biological
women
when you start getting into all these
when you get into all these exceptions
like then there are people that are face
consequences and usually it's not you
it's someone else yeah I do think the
transgender Wing was important because
it's obviously it's keeping trans women
safe from men but it's also keeping you
know it's just women safe so I think
that was a good but that is an example
of a compromise right we didn't just
know the trans women no but I would I
would I would
this makes your brain smoothly I like
black and white thinking too so I I
understand can I just say something it's
not about thinking black and white it's
just you know how some people well I was
raised to think that if I'm a woman I go
into the woman's bathroom it might have
brothers when they go toilet they go to
the men's bathroom buy at home use the
same toilet at home we use the same
toilet because
because we are family and because we are
friends because we have family on
because we are friends what was the last
thing you said you go to a house party
when you're meeting people that you
don't know but you're still using the
same toilet yes 100 you survive them
proud of you yeah
but at a house party I would go at a
house party I would go with the girls
and you talk in the bathroom I would not
bring a guy to do that and you know it's
different like we go we go into it it is
an experience you know that you know I'm
enjoying this because I'm not the most
it's great I enjoy it but um when it
comes to some bathrooms specifically
um I don't want to disregard how anxious
and scared women often feel in general
like if you don't know somewhere where
you're going and you're out in public
you're always kind of on edge and
Society kind of pushes you to be this
way because if you're not on edge and
constantly have your guard up you're
often blamed for things that are bad
that happen to you so you're either
constantly anxious or constantly not
paying attention and then blamed for the
bad things that happen to you and that's
not trans women's fault but it's
something we should take into
consideration just the experience of
being a CIS woman again women both both
women we are protected classes and
whilst we have some similarities we are
also different we're like two circles
that partly overlap but don't completely
overlap and it's important not to just
complete discredit these differences
um okay so where do we land on bathrooms
so you guys bathrooms I think it should
be fine fine
all right who says no I'm gonna I just
want him they have to get their own unit
okay half and half I mean own units is
good like I used to keep everything you
need to put a camera outside the
cubicles
it's like a unisex cubicle you can just
have cubicle cubicle cubicles
in front of the mirror the mirror will
still be there for you there will just
be a camera watch and you have your chat
doing your makeup so that everyone's
safe when you walk in a hammer now
because then again it's like we have to
make all these exceptions for like one
percent of the population like everyone
should like it so if it's only one
percent of the population like I just
think that we're where these people um
you know we are a
what's the words uh
when something's like a small amount of
you know I'm saying that it's such a
small percentage I just don't see how
like it's it's gonna be an issue you
know for these these type of people
because it's not an issue till it
becomes an issue they're so there's such
a small percentage you said just one
percent like if there was there's one
percent of millionaires okay if there
was yeah but that's different because
you know that's that's not a league
that's not like a league that's just
people's successes and stuff but if
you're trying to put people together
in terms of like leagues of sports and
things like that is going to be
difficult with just one percent to form
a whole league of just one gender of
people and that the more we're speaking
about it the more I'm starting to see
that
it wouldn't be a bad thing you know it
genuinely would not be a bad thing to
have a separate but then there would
need to be a more uh like more more
amounts of people like let's say for
example female football female football
you know 30 years ago didn't really
exist I've I don't know how correct that
is but I'm just kind of giving an
estimate But as time progresses it's
getting more watch it's getting more
appreciated more people are going
towards it but initially there wasn't
enough women playing football for there
to be a league and I think with
transgender people the more transgender
people that come forward and say you
know what I'd like to pay play a sport
and and face these type of difficulties
of prejudice and whether it's Prejudice
or just you know technical or whatever
it is I just thinking create this league
you know I think in life you know we've
kind of said that we shouldn't be
excluded from anything and I think some
things here people should be excluded
from like for example I don't really
think women
um like we don't play football I mean
not not really it's not really it's a
very friend right so we can but we can
talk about like in the normal school the
normal College you're not going to go on
and find a football team right and you
know maybe there's special colleges that
do that on occasion when there's a high
population of women that want to play
but the rule is there's no Football
League when it comes to sports I think
it's rather than nobody's saying the
same thing with the bathrooms like okay
if there's a ton in one area fine but
like demanding that there's bathrooms in
all these locations when we could just
go by biological sex it's easier yeah
but you don't okay so biological
mistakes you see someone walk into the
movement's toilet with a bed yeah you
can't give them a little side eye yeah
it's gonna be great if I walk into the
women if you're walking through Miss
toilet and you see somebody walking
behind you walking with a beard and a
penis you can't give them a side eye
because they will be but I mean if we're
gonna be honest I'd rather either I'd
rather neither but you know but we got
to go to biology yes people exist and I
think biologically it wouldn't work that
way
unless unless people continue to use the
the bathrooms of the gender that they've
that they are claiming yeah so that they
were signed at Birth or that they were
signed above it's either that or like
you say you know they they make a
special bathroom for
transgender people because this idea of
a a transgender woman with a beard going
into a woman's toilet or a transgender
man with breasts going into men's toilet
is just absolutely crazy I mean it
doesn't make anything I think it's
crazier than someone with male parts
going into a woman's bathroom I think
that's way crazier I would take someone
with a beard over like I don't know
I would I would take a beard over a dick
but you don't know what that beer comes
with yeah so if someone was the same
female at Birth they've transitioned to
male and you're saying that they need to
go with their biological sex yeah or
their their gender assigned at Birth
um so they could have gone through every
single process to have bottom surgery
have Top surgery they've been through
hormone therapy they've been on hormones
for like 10 years they look like a they
look like a cisgender man but they've
just followed you into a woman's toilet
because you said that biological women
women's toilet's already completely
separate cubicles am I missing something
like I've never seen a transgender
person's PPE like ever yeah
but the whole point I do think changing
rooms is a bit different but bathrooms
is just like
I just I don't I don't think we should
be forced to share a bathroom with men
like that I'm just trying to figure out
how you'd know like unless like someone
was obviously close to that it's close
to the beginning of their transition I
mean we already have a lot of units and
I don't know I don't know how you would
know this is I mean it's it's pretty uh
I mean I'm not even trying to be rude
it's pretty it's pretty obvious like you
can you can usually tell like even in
this room it was pretty easy for me to
tell but does it really matter unless
they do something really bad does it
matter like if you just see them coming
in or out like yeah
you're forcing me to pretend that
there's something that they're not and I
don't think that you can still think
they're what they are you just yeah
everyone's in town
but we're supposed to have the it's
supposed to be women the women's locker
room the women's bathroom and so it's
like when we have to be okay with them
coming in again it's like you're asking
me to accept that there's something that
they're not no I don't know because your
opinion at that point would have to be
relevant to the person using the
bathroom so like for example if a
transgender person came into the
bathroom and had to put up with your
negative Prejudice and negativity yes
then it's up to that person if they give
you air time if if they think that
you're just something
I'm actually like a Karen so I would go
to the like manager and I would say hey
there's a man in the bathroom and they
probably ask you to leave so who who
would they probably ask you well in this
world culture yes but I'm trying to stop
do they really look look completely like
a man or are they a transgender woman
they're trying the best see I get really
confused all the words like the transcis
I I just confuses me a bit but if we're
gonna go to the men that become women I
would say very easy to tell like at that
tournament I could say that one that one
that one I would say the other way
around it's a little harder but it's
still pretty the trans women that you've
met would all of them bother you or
somebody others
all of them I would not want in the
bathroom with me
yeah I feel like we should base being
sort of wary of people on when they
actually do something bad no but again
the policies again the Pol because the
issue is if we let allow them in the
bathrooms then what's next then it's the
prisons then it's the sports like it
just never stops so I mean there's
always something they're going to be
fighting they have already regulated at
least in the UK they've regulated the
prisons pretty well I do think there is
still work to be done with sports but
these are all very individuals no they
have different yeah I'm about to get
kicked out of the league for it to be
honest because I said something about it
I'll be honest I think the the biggest
issue is you're just calling trans women
men I feel like if you'd use their PC
language they probably couldn't have had
as much but why do why do I have to
because it's like but why do I have to
change why do I have to change my
language because because again again
I I wouldn't say I wouldn't I wouldn't
say that it's the same when it's what
you're born as it's your biology so it's
like it's like it's for me it's just
confusing because if someone doesn't say
no but if you know the word in other
languages negro means black yeah secret
is different from it doesn't
matter yeah it doesn't matter
you just cut me yeah it's a terminology
that people use and black people do not
like when it's used by people that are
not black okay this is classes
disrespectful so
my example it doesn't need to be taken
for word for word is if you've got a
broad enough mind you'll be able to look
at the example and see that you're
calling someone a word and a phrase that
they find disrespectful could be someone
that's obese you're calling them fat if
you're a respectful person you wouldn't
call someone a terminology that offends
them if you're a disrespectful person
you won't mind because you would like to
offend people make few people
because I don't agree with that because
I think saying if someone's fat and they
deserve to die or something I don't
think saying like fatty exactly my
argument was my argument was no my
argument was to call anyone my argument
was black people are not born Negroes
but trans women are born men what are
black people born they are born as black
people and what does negro mean in other
languages no no negro negro if you go
and check this do you mean like Spanish
words
I know the history but the examples you
know it was used as a slur that's
different you being born as a man is not
but now you guys are demanding that we
change our language
it's just confusing so I need to know if
we're talking about men or trans women
so if you're if you keep calling trans
women men I don't know what we're
talking about at a certain point we kind
of have to use these labels otherwise
this whole thing it's not it's not it's
not the original way human beings have
been thinking for the past couple of
years that's causing these problems it's
trans people have been around way of
thinking no but yeah I've been around
but there has been a way of thinking for
the past couple of thousands of years
yeah it wasn't spoke about like the get
with the gay community not a lot of
people came out that they were gay for a
very long time they hid it and it's the
same with the Trans community and not
like what it is until until they until
they feel comfortable enough to discuss
their sexuality their gender they are
not gonna come out and say oh I'm this
oh I mean gay people suffered in the
same way that trans people did right
everyone assumed all the gay men in the
bathrooms are trying to the kids
and there was a lot of pedophiles like
we kind of evolved our thinking from
this
um and I I have a lot of empathy towards
people that are wary about their kids
being trans it's a lot and there's a lot
of discussion about whether X Y or Z is
safe and Etc
um but the reality is we did move on
from that I want to say that was like
the 90s where we were having these types
of George Michael yeah yeah
um
but then I'm also not really convinced
there is like a transgender ideology I
know this kind of upsets a lot of people
I do think that how things are is a mess
I do think in certain situations it's
not quite there yet I think in a lot of
sports it's a mess I think I I
completely understand the anxiety
especially around changing rooms because
being naked is a vulnerability and I
don't want to like I'm a CIS woman I
don't like being naked around anyone it
doesn't feel good and if if one of the
people was like a a pre-op transgender
person it would feel uncomfortable but I
feel uncomfortable all the time so I
don't know how much the base my feeling
on what should be policy I do think that
these things could be fixed easily it
just everyone should have their
own cubicles and but I also realized
that in a lot of situations there aren't
there isn't that yet right if you're
playing sports in a place that doesn't
have those like facilities that sucks
for you and I don't want to like
disregard that
again like CIS women are a particular
class transgender women are protected
class and I think people are trying to
mean protected class we have protected
um you know when it comes to like the
law and things when it comes to sexism
and things that connectively affect us
um there are certain things that make us
protected
um but while there is for transgender
women is a little bit different well 10
different people in general but um
anyone that is a protected class is like
black people for example or
it's just different
um things that put in place
to consider that we're you know
different from a minority that's the
word I was looking for yeah
we understand what you were saying
earlier like why I should be punished
for my speech when what I'm saying is
true no you shouldn't be punished so so
like with the with the you know I was
talking to to you because you you said
you wouldn't have like been in that
situation if you just use their pronouns
so it's like why do I have to change my
language when what I am saying is true
I'm just saying so it's not necessarily
that you're wrong or that you need to
change your language I'm saying if you
want to win a flight and not necessarily
just get kicked out of the volleyball
league or kicked out of this or that you
have to adopt the way that other people
are thinking or they're just going to
completely describe disregard you and
you might see that as being really
unfair but
the world is you have to adapt to the
way that other people are being so that
you can play them at their game and if
you don't do that they just don't care
and they're not going to engage with you
they're going to get rid of you and to
be fair calling a trans woman a man is
kind of transphobic I can't I get like
it is but that but they are
they're a biological man but they've
transitioned to a trans woman I think
it's it's fine and and you know in in
personal relationships like I mean I'm
not gonna call someone their opposite
pronoun like when I meet them yeah when
you know the mirror yeah but but I'm but
I'm saying like I can't tweet that I
don't want men in our locker rooms I
can't tweet that I don't want men in our
sport but you could I can't I don't want
transgender women in my locker but what
I'm saying is true though and there
shouldn't even be like a butt you could
phrase it like that like why do we have
to change our speech when we're talking
about things that are true it's because
even if you don't think that trans women
are women they're also not really men
anymore either so they're kind of
they're their own thing like and they're
under the umbrella so I see women as an
umbrella term okay so like CIS women are
there but trans women are under this
umbrella and I do think they they are a
protected class they they suffer from a
lot of things that we do some to a worse
extent like the the rate of death for
black Trans women is really bad
especially in America
like they do suffer a lot and I do
appreciate these things have you seen
the rate of death of men
uh death of men yes by other men no just
the rate of death of men because I just
think they probably rule problem of this
whole thing is the censorship I think if
I was talking about murder rather than
yeah no no I I again but I just think
the real problem is censorship I think
trans women trans people should be
allowed to do whatever they want but you
can't censor other people's opinions no
you can't yeah that's wrong I'm not
saying that they all should be censored
I'm saying
but that's basically what the policies
and Society is doing they are censoring
people even from what you're saying the
way you've been saying like well you
should phrase it different why can't we
just say it how we want to see you can't
say it but you just need to be aware
that you may cause offense and if you're
happy to do that and happy to receive
the backlash
I don't care about a fence that's cool
people can be offended my issue is when
I'm I'm now getting kicked out of a
league and now I'm getting other
repercussions because I said something
that's true because some people might
wanna it might not want to endorse you
so some organizations might not want to
endorse you knowing that you have yeah
and I think and I think that's wrong and
that's why in the same way even even if
someone if someone was a super far
leftist like if you you played on my you
know maybe you're kind of left but like
on my volleyball league like I think
it's wrong that they be they cannot play
because of an opinion I mean I agree I
mean like I do music and I think that
you know within the art the art the
Artistry world and all of that stuff you
know people want you to have like a
certain type of personality and be super
friendly and all that stuff and kind of
being nonchalant and and private doesn't
really get people anywhere so I I agree
that you know certain things should be
separated you know you should separate
who an individual is to what they do
because sometimes in my opinion some of
the
some of the most magnificent people are
weird and that's what makes them so
magnificent because they're different
they're a little bit strange to some
people you know and I think it's okay
for everyone to have an opinion it's
okay for everyone to speak about their
opinion you know these debates are good
you know it spreads awareness it spreads
knowledge but we have to also be aware
that sometimes we're going to cause
offense you know what I mean to some
people yeah I don't know I don't care
not just that don't agree with us but
it's the way in which we we word things
it's the way in which we say things you
know we can put on like you said we can
put our opinions across in a way that
doesn't cause offense people will listen
to me like okay I only really get to
pick offensive or actually productive
you can't really do both and it's fine
if you want to say things the way we
can't we can't wear it our only two
options are offensive and productive if
you don't seem reasonable to the other
party in the night oh yeah but I can't
help how I seem like I can't help their
feelings and and at the end of the day
it's like if we're talking about things
that are true they're true and I can't
help I can't help that I can't help how
someone else feels about a fact about
something that is true that's fine and
it's not necessarily about feelings but
it's like enough of the population has
agreed on a let's just say societal
whatever no I I think it's a small
percentage of the population that's
pushing the society if you're engaging
with that small percentage of the
population and they're in charge of
governing bodies that affect your sport
well yeah and that's the issue in the
middle and the issue is is that they get
in charge of these organizations when I
was interviewing girls at the tournament
a lot of people didn't agree with it a
lot of people were against it but they
can't say anything because okay yeah
because of these yeah because of the
governing body so it's like I can't even
speak out that I don't want them in my
sports I mean and if I'm being honest
and no but the the issue is like this
language I'm sorry it's so confusing to
the average person's CIS Tran I'm sorry
I'm not even trying to be rude it's
confusing
gender fluid all these words gender
fluids
I don't know what any of this means
women no but then there's no then
there's there's non-binary gender flu
doesn't really matter that much it
doesn't but what if you're calling you
know aside from it just being
confusing because we do need to
differentiate you do it's because of
what you're saying you want to you want
to differentiate otherwise
a man and then if you've transitioned
you're called a trans woman no I don't
want new language
I want the same language we've used for
the last 500 years transgender has
existed
so it's new right in the 80s
anxious degrees angst and Greece had
trans people everywhere
people that don't conform to a single
gender across the board I mean I just I
I I'm you might be right but just
because it's not necessarily a societal
terms or even like no like if you think
even about being um like homosexual for
example quite like homosexuality pretty
much quite eradicated from from society
it was only seen Underground
because well for one Colonial loss made
homosexual homosexual Behavior illegal
but it took a long long time for gay
people to come out with the Woodworks it
was illegal someplace exactly there were
some there were certain people like for
example there's like a whole um pretty
much a whole generation of like gay men
that just aren't talked about because
that was before
before it was legal when being gay could
still aligned you in jail what what's
your what's your what's so like trans
people trans people were pretty much
eradicated from the Forefront of society
but it doesn't mean they weren't there
it means that you may not have seen them
they may not have been discussed
we can't prove they were common either
we can't really
conception exceptions but it's not
really I feel like the only difference
is we used to call them transsexuals
rather than transgender but they're like
The Rocky Horror show or they were just
they were just that one yeah that no one
really spoke about they were just part
of society it is older than all of us in
the room so we should take that into
consideration well like across the board
this is a new thing and like it's in the
last hundred years
ago Adam and Eve it was there I guess
it's new in a sense where it's been
getting more exposure you know it's more
to talk to us doing it you know and in
that regard but I think that's necessary
you know I think people need to be more
aware of these things I think the
movement that black people had the
movement that women had the movement
that gay people had the movement that
you know
I want to take it back well you don't
want to work
well you know I mean I just want you to
be able to advocate for what you believe
in but actually get somewhere if you
don't start to adopt at least some of
the language you're not gonna get
anywhere they're not going to listen I
just think like why should I be forced
to learn this what do you want to win do
you want to get somewhere or do you just
want to insult people because you can't
do it I I don't think it's insulting to
say that I don't well again I feel like
a lot of things are insulting that's
what women do we feel like everything's
insulting so it's like you know we can't
base facts off of our feelings yeah but
do you want to win or do you just want
when I'm just away though like what if
these are these are my options okay I
could say it nicely they're still gonna
do the same thing or I have to live with
their delusion I have to use their
language I have to I have to have them
in my bathrooms and I have to to play
with them is it really delusional to
call them trans women because they're
still not CIS women they're not
biological I would say if we're having
them if we're having if we're pretending
that there's something that they're not
which I I would say it is
I would say a trans
a dude that transitioned to a woman
sorry
um I would say even though they got the
surgery even though they're dressing
like it they're still not women
but but when you when you put them in
our bathrooms it's like now I have to
pretend and act like it's normal but you
don't have to pretend that you don't
have the same as us it's up to you
because this is what I would do if if a
man walked into my locker room I would
go get the manager and say get them out
but I can't do that now why do you want
to be I can't do that that's who I am
I've been I've been tattling on this
yeah I've been tattling on on parties
you know so my neighbor throws a party
I'm calling you know what I mean that's
I'm not the food's bad I'll get the I do
it but so now I have to do a different
Behavior based on them based on how
they're dressed we don't have to but I'm
just saying as someone that knows you
I'm like do you want to actually have
success and get somewhere then that's
what I would do but you don't have to do
that I'm just saying do you want to
actually make change and say hey it's
not cool for transgender women to be in
team sports where there's they have
Advantage for X Y and Z like if you want
to get somewhere you kind of have to
adapt at least a little no there's no
winning question
argument sounds like your argument
sounds like blackmail yeah how am I
blackmailing no it does it does it does
sound like blackmail what you're saying
yeah
um because what you're saying is that we
have to in order to be okay with trans
trans women and trans men we have to
change our language we have to like no
you don't have to be okay and you don't
have to change your language I'm saying
if you want to communicate with other
people that have this the way that they
are we're like
be fair even I think like calling a
trans woman a man is
if you if you want change use my
language if you want if you want us to
do what you want you have to use my
language we're being forced okay of
course what is being transphobic right
it's just it's as similar as being I
don't know racist you're using
inappropriate language it's a type of
prejudice and you can't just kind of
ignore this as you're trying to engage
with other people on the other side to
make actual progress but the thing is I
don't care what you do do it do what you
want but again it's when you force your
opinions on me but the thing is that's
my problem I think you have a good
argument like I do think within team
sports for women for CIS women
biological women whatever there are some
like
um advantages trans women would have
which probably makes it unfair
um so for me the sad part is that I feel
like you're approaching the argument
wrong because I think you have a good a
point but it's lost in the language and
it's disregarded because people just
write you off as being transphobic yeah
I mean you can feel that way but at the
end of the day like it's it's not really
how I feel like I don't give a I'm
like trying to give you advice it's very
funny how her argument is very one-sided
because she says we um just because the
transgender people don't like what we
say they disregard it but she's saying
we shoot this history God no no what
you're saying you're saying we shouldn't
disregard what the transgender people
are saying to make them feel comfortable
but they should disregard what we are
saying just so they can feel comfortable
so it's a very one-sided that's what's
happening it does happen the other way
around like we and we you're already
calling them delusional XYZ like you do
disregate okay I call women delusional
too to be fair all human beings on the
planet are delusional if you do not
accept that then you are the problem
or delusional can you can you look at it
from my point of view I'm a young person
right and growing up
there wasn't anything to do with trans
like it's a very new thing it's very
very new to understand how trans people
are like have become if that makes sense
so it is very
hard for someone like me to now try like
change my language and say they and them
very perfect I think if you have a good
intention it doesn't matter too much
would you would you guys think about
people that are religious that you know
they've been raised and their religion
obviously goes back for a very long time
and a lot of people still I'm so I'm
Muslim I don't think I could ever be
comfortable with accepting new terms for
you know like I just I just don't think
I'd ever do it like I don't think I'd
you know I think it's fine if you don't
want to accept things but also you're
not really gonna be able to engage in
arguments if you're not so the point of
arguments and debate is you're trying to
meet someone in the middle so that you
can have a conducive you can't you can't
engage in an argument unless you engage
it in the way that I think is right it
was basically no you need to meet people
in the middle yeah but why don't they
mean but why don't they meet her in the
middle probably would meet you in the
middle
not if they don't if not not unless
she's forced to use language that she's
not coming comfortable using which she
just said is there's religious do you
think there's any difference between a
man but we can talk about religion but
that would be a whole other subjects
like any difference at all like can we
not just use it because it's confusing
AF if we don't so transgender woman I
think it's I think it's more confusing
when you add it all over but it's not
like men men are trying to compete with
women in sports or men men are trying to
like turn off in our bathrooms and stuff
it's there has to be a differentiation
or the com the composition is
confusing no no I say the men that like
that are trying to be women that's how I
would say it well that are trying to be
women or transitioning
answers I would say I would say trying
because you you can't do it yeah
they can't carry children they can't
carry their children okay some
biological women have problems doing
that yeah and like like I've said
earlier that doesn't make them any less
of a woman yeah some men cannot
impregnate their sperm for whatever
reason has this one but the difference
is trans people can never do it that's
fine how many people how many
heterosexual people have had children
I'm pretty sure every single transition
I'm pretty sure every single transgender
person on the planet was born from a
heterosexual man and woman just because
someone is born man and born a woman it
doesn't give them the right to be
parents you know much f'd up stuff
happens because of men and women having
kids how much so much stuff happens like
I haven't seen one case so far
where there's been a LGBT couple that's
had a child and they've become a mass
murderer bombing schools all of the
stuff that you all of the crazy stuff
that happens
I understand like what all the issue is
with you know transgender people when
there's a lot of crazy stuff that goes
on in the world that's not from
transgender or LGBT the lgbts
but I've told you my issue my issue is
that again they're forcing us to live in
their delusion but it's their peaceful
community then LGBT communities okay
okay so so if they want to do their
thing in their Community fine I don't
give up I don't care
the issue is when you got men coming
into my bathrooms men coming into my
sports men coming into women's spaces
and forcing me to pretend that they're
women that's where I have an issue but
that's your Prejudice and that's the
problem
you have to go through that yourself
that's something that you're gonna have
to come through I don't know if there's
been people that have felt the same way
about people of different races you know
you know people that I've got different
disabilities
to do with it's literally to do yeah but
it's a transition over you know I think
they would feel the same way if I said I
am now black and now I would like all of
I would like to be the head of the black
student union I would like to be the
head of all these things yeah and they
would have to pretend that I'm black I
guess I think and I think that that's
the only equivalent yeah that's right
and you know what maybe in 50 years time
we'll see what science does
if they make a way for that to happen we
can have another conversation but right
now this is the conversation
like that sex doesn't or it already
doesn't exist on a binary there are
intersex people there are people that
have genetic differences that does fall
out of XX and X Y so it's there is
already reasons for why we see things a
little bit differently whereas with
black and white is just like but if you
don't make any sense
if you look on a DNA level those classes
of people are classed as abnormal it's
an anomalies not natural it's not you
know that's the point
do you know what genetic differences
always used to lead to in the past it
was called Evolution
yes and there are genetic differences
that have led to Devolution
obviously but the point is by natural
selection there are people that have
existed that we're not um I did not fit
into the normal binary system and things
like that have been like natural
selection takes care of things like that
naturally but human beings because of
Technology because of all this
advancement we're not trying to enforce
these things that if we were to leave it
to actual nature it would actually phase
out hermaphrodites as they were called
and we now call them differently have
existed since the dawn of time yes they
haven't been eradicated
Adam and Eve when yeah the point is we
can blame Adam and Eve genetic nature if
you have to leave everything to Nature
and take science out of it and leave
everything to Nature how we're designed
for one eventually at a long enough time
span
gay people can reproduce I'm
transsexuals or whatever would
eventually die out if you had to leave
everything to Nature and human beings
when going to Tampa you're talking about
how many species are there how many
species are there on this planet where
an individual specimen can change its
gender that happens in nature
design human beings are not designed to
do that that's fine everybody can't
change their nature through their mind
yeah yeah in my opinion you know
the whole point of viewing people a
human woman becoming pregnant by herself
now this is a very rare occurrence okay
but the thing with genetics is things
are weird and we we do there is a woman
that got pregnant by herself were you
guys following her making sure that she
didn't go and inseminate herself that's
this is the thing like this story
scientific weirdness is a thing that
happens
just as how twins can like eat each
other and then they have a different
genetic I have a question um
so I'm curious
um when you guys transitioned how old
were you I didn't even know that I guess
we can't tell trans really appreciate
that what I mean I just that's like
that's something that we should have the
opportunity
I just figured this is what you came on
the podcast to talk about
there's still you know you don't
necessarily out your gay friends okay
but you can you can tell
I didn't well I don't know if anyone
knows I'm not trying to be rude I'm just
being honest I don't think Paul said
anything wrong I think obviously I can
understand why you said like you know
it's your kind of position to say and
tell people but then
this is I just I feel like if you have
if you were a man before and now you're
a female if you're a female and now
you're a man do you not think that it's
facts like do you not think that you
know you still I don't know it's okay to
say they're still biologically male or
biologically female but if they're
presenting as a okay
do you want to answer the question or no
what was the question when did you
transition how old so I came out when I
was 28. okay I've started my medical
transition two years ago okay and what
was the process the process like of
transitioning I'm just curious how
um in the process okay you're still I
don't know how it works
I'm in the process okay
for two years okay uh what about you
I'll start when I was 25. okay
um so my question is did they look at
you guys as hormones
before because I I've worked I just I'm
only asking because I worked with a
doctor and he said sometimes trans
people they think they're the opposite
gender but really it's like their
hormones are really offer myself
yeah so like with me yeah I've always
been a boy
since I was a kid I've I've always been
a little bit and you know I'm I was born
in 1988 I grew up in the 90s yeah
by the time I was 18 it was like
early I can't remember now but you know
whatever the timeline is but it's a
different time now than it is for them
and I can only imagine for people that
were born you know earlier running than
me but for me I had to pretend for a
long time that a lot boys
I mean I had to pretend
that I wasn't uh a boy trapped in a
girl's body because of of of losing my
friends
in people's opinions
it was a lonely time
um but I've always been a boy I've never
been interested in all of that stuff and
my parents put me in a girl's high
school and I'd swear to you yeah I I was
looking far and wide so the tomboys my
question my question is more like I'm
just I'm just curious if they did
anything to prevent you from
transitioning when you went to the
doctor so if they said let's get your
hormones checked out first let's do
therapy first or did they did they just
have you transition they did the therapy
so it wasn't really therapy it was like
they just asked you questions and like I
was never uh I've always like cared
about what people think like I've always
I've always cared about what people
think you know people's opinions of me
has always mattered to me
and I got to the point where I was so
unhappy
that I just I had to put myself first
like I had to really just say like
you're not happy with your life you're
not happy with how you feel about
yourself
people will tell me I'm pretty and I
just thought ugly
like I just didn't want I did I just
didn't like any of it you know I mean it
was really difficult it's it's it's it's
and it goes back way before so I'm just
curious when you went to the doctors
they had you do therapy so they spoke to
me they asked me about my my past
how long I've wanted to do this for and
all of these things and and so forth but
I was really I was really excited I was
like look I need to do this I'm 25 I
look in the mirror I don't see a 25 year
old man
and I felt crap I felt really crap you
know I mean even when I started my
transition I didn't get any facial hair
for a long time I thought okay so so
when you went it's important so did they
did they do therapy first I'm just
asking what do they do to prevent it or
do they just give you guys drugs they
let you talk they give you an open space
and they judge you based on in my
opinion in my experience this was like
10 years ago but
they they they ask you relevant
questions and they basis base it on what
they perceive how serious so therapy yes
or no I just want do they have you do
therapy first yes or no
I I personally wouldn't call it therapy
in my opinion
did you say you were 25 when you started
me yeah yeah okay so he wasn't a kid
anyway right I'm not saying they should
or they shouldn't I'm just asking okay
so yes no okay or sorry yes no but but
the same thing how long did you do
therapy for I had 20 sessions with
therapy I had 20 sessions of therapy
that's like over what three months and
then okay
um and then
um yeah like I there was quite a
rigorous
um
like a discussion a couple discussions
with
um psychologists
um you know like it was I was 28 when I
went to my GP about it
um I was 32 or 33
uh just before when I was 32 when I
started hormones
I had already thought about every single
possibility this is not necessarily
something I actually wanted to do to my
body but this is something that actually
saved my life
um I like um
like you I I knew from quite Young from
when I was about four that was very very
different there was something that
didn't connect
um I tried to ignore that I tried to
absolutely eradicate that from my being
especially as it was always said to me
so negatively oh you want to be a boy in
it
all of this it was always extremely
negative connotations so I really tried
to and that was from being young there
was there was like we you know they were
they were transgender people within my
community when I was a kid in South
London okay so but you did roughly six
months a year of therapy yeah okay which
one six months or a year just over six
months okay six months of therapy and
then did they check you guys hormones
first they checked mine they checked my
they didn't want so did you have like
low high testosterone like what two
minutes I don't know they didn't ask
okay because I I just imagined that
would be something they'd go through
with you if they're checking it it's
impossible I mean to be honest you don't
remember no I got ADHD as well
what about you they check your hormones
they do yeah yeah yeah they check they
checked my hormones and stuff but I
can't remember what the results was I
will say there is more more to it than
just having abnormally hot I am an owner
of abnormally high testosterone I take
two anti-androgens
um myself because I have polycystic
ovary syndrome
um insulin resistance hi
um these medications have stopped me
from experiences and some of the
medications would be the same as what a
trans woman would take
um so I do think that being a trans
woman there's more to it than just
having high a lot of women just have
high testosterone especially if you're
doing sports and stuff right no I know
that's true
um Sports does raise your um
testosterone but but I I just worked
with a doctor he said he's been doing it
for 20 years I think it's good to get
your yeah no I'm just wondering if they
do that first I'm gonna do super chats
for a second and then we'll go on to the
next questions
um these are not my opinions some of
these might be mean and I'm sorry if
they are okay Black Phoenix imagine
losing a leg or being born with one leg
and then saying I'm not human or forcing
My Religion on people crazy right Dr
David Baker I'm a flower dressed you
aren't a biologist intersex people are
one in ten thousand hermaphrodites are
one in seven million um that is not an
argument against the existence of gender
binary it's the exceptions that prove
the rule 90 free-toe pie can y'all get
testy cancer no stupid
um ND empty hands I knew both of them
were trans observed Vinnie um to the Hat
guy the Colorado Springs shooter
identified as non-binary the Denver
shooter identified as trans that Amber
Dean shooter identified as trans and
Nashville shooter identified as trans
fact check meme
dragon stallion1001 guy wearing
um the carpet on the couch look up
Audrey Hale took out the kids in
Nashville School diancy sunglasses on
the sofa if you had a 10 year old
daughter and a 40 year old man came into
the changing room and took his clothes
off do you honestly think that would be
okay lady in the middle all you feel and
thinks are crazy 90 free-toe Pie New
York Hat there was a trans shooter at a
Christian's kid that happened our
Christian kids school that happened
recently stay away from kids in society
you and the lady next to you are no good
um Asian
um or Dragon stallion one why is it
transphobic when you are called why
aren't you called heterophobic I'm 90
Frito pie there is a pedo movement that
is getting pushed feminism and weak
women or men like the ones on the couch
or the spearhead of it they're LED
leading the population rule
um 90 free-toe pie given all the
evidence feminism we'll call the age of
consent to be lowered in our lifetime
Pale Lady as Lee lead by majority and
popular rule a uh the reason that of the
few trans men get attacked is because
they trick straight men into bed and
blow them just like just like the most
crimes the Judiciary System handles
those crimes the same as all others
Adam Sutton creatures evolved to
recognize gender before recognizing up
and down it is our most fundamental
understanding you're asking kids
um real kids already struggling to grow
to question the most basic part of their
being Dragon
stallion1001 the Scandinavian countries
have figured out that the cure for
gender dysphoria is allowing the child
to go through the entirety of puberty
and fixes the dysphoria 99 of the time
Doug MPA rapper guy is an idiot race is
a social construct sex and biology is
not simps like him that are going to let
women get graped and deleted Adam Sutton
you can go to Corn sites and see
thousands of trans people masturbating
in public girls bathrooms men
impregnating women in female prisons
young women being disabled in high
school sports this has just begun Dr
David Baker
out of the estimates of one percent of
the population who are trans
approximately 90 to 95 percent either
don't have a gender dysphoria diagnosis
or don't have one that meets pre-2015
standards prior to pressure out uh prior
to the pressure to hand out diagnosis
like candy Daniel you're not assigned
dad's birth you're born as adventurous
filmmaker if I identify myself as a
seven handed swords Swordsmen who
breathes fire should Society expect me
and listen to all my demands obviously
not enter black dragon um gender
dysphoria is the lack of understanding
and acceptance of one biological gender
transgenderism is not found in nature or
biology no AMT or money or surgery
changes nature get there a peanut
surgery
um Ash heart when letting when letting
not the non-normal be the normal then
you are opening the door to other things
humans don't walk around in public naked
but soon that might be the norm
the women in the couch says a lot of
nothing just Rambles and can't land the
plane video by poor man's pod will show
the panel in the panel the difference in
sports also the women or the men just
identifying and winning the women's
Awards Dr David Baker a most male to
female athletes are clearly opportunists
one level above grapes who transitioned
to go to female prisons they are
spitting in the face of people who
actually suffer from gender dysphoria
and are at risk of self-harm Adam Sutton
there is absolutely no there's
absolutely something to stop men from
using women's bathrooms it's called the
law arrest and fines um dragon
styling1001
it's all about trans feelings what about
the biological women's feelings who want
safety in their private areas Doug MPA
who when are the guys on the couch going
to transition a dragon
stallion1001 BS trans and women can't
get a biological woman pregnant at least
six California women prisoners got
pregnant by a trans woman at locked up
Doug MPA the girl in the dress is lying
about everything the 100 mile record for
men is 10 hours 51 minutes female is 12
hours 52 minutes male gymnasts can do
anything a female gymnast can do dragon
stallion a Riley Gaines just talked
about trans women undressing no bottom
surgery undressing in front of the whole
team there was a congressional hearing
Dragon stallion 1001 London County
School Trans Am girl grape to underage
women in a woman's restroom and the
school tried to cover it up
um
okay I think that's Let me refresh it
really quick also guys make sure you
like the video that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these live streams and also let me know
in the chat what topics you want us to
cover next week what type of panels
you'd want to see um
okay
I think that's it okay guys
um make sure you like the video okay
we're good
that was impressive I was alone oh my
gosh yeah I know you get good at it
after a year and a half
um but they still make fun of how I read
them okay
um so my next question is do you think
that people with gender dysphoria need
therapy before transitioning sure yes
they need to make sure that that's a
decision that they're making is 100 what
they want to do because if you don't if
you like halfway through transitioning
you say you turn around and say you
don't want to be that particular gender
you're transitioning to be it's going to
be a waste of time if that makes sense
it's a huge decision it's a very big
decision it's so like
just like the basic like you as in
yourself you have like come to a
conclusion that you are so I'm not a
female I'm actually a man so it's like
you're gonna go through that whole
process I think it's important to get
that therapy first and then just go from
there and then you can really make that
final decision so it's only fair really
isn't it yeah for sure well everyone
agreed on this one no 100 things
I was even someone that beforehand was
it would be like I'm not talking to
anyone about my ish no one needs to hear
my ish you could just stay in my head it
fine and you know what like it took
about
16 sessions for me to actually really
talk about the things that I needed to
talk about and not necessarily like
transitioning but just like things that
have culminated in like um like who I am
today like the trauma I've been through
things I've experienced and so on and so
forth like I think it's actually really
important and like to to actually have
that space where you can sit and you can
discuss that stuff and you can talk
about it and when it comes to transition
I do think you should have therapy
before you before you even think about
transitioning like it is it is a massive
massive step to take obviously society
as a whole doesn't necessarily agree
with our existence so it is hard I too
I'm Muslim so I had to have that take
that into consideration as well
um I have like a lot of religious family
members both Christian and Muslim
um and
you know like I had to think about that
I also had to think about where I stood
in my in my relationship with God in my
spirituality as well and you know what
like the way I see is I am very very
blessed to have been given the
perspective of a female to understand
like what it's like to be
um objectified what it's like to be
spoken down at work or not to be taken
seriously or to you know like to have
your feelings null and void because
you're just hormonal yeah so I
understand what that's like and I really
really appreciate being given that
opportunity and that you know that
perspective
but did you see did you see a
psychiatrist too
and I just saw a counselor okay but
either way I feel very blessed I've have
been given that perspective however I
was not comfortable with my body I was
22 stone in that body I've lost over 10
Stone
um since understanding who I am and how
I operate I feel so much more
comfortable I don't claim that I'm a man
if anything I am a very beautiful
balance of both I'm very very proud of
my femininity I'm very proud of my
masculinity the outside now matches the
inside I don't pretend to be something
that other people think I'm not I am
both we strive for I don't see yeah like
non-binary then I don't even consider
myself non-binary if I label myself as
Taz that's how I label myself I wouldn't
say to anybody I wouldn't try to
um
coerce someone into thinking that I you
know that I'm a man that that I was born
with Mira genitalia that's not what I
will never do but I would hope that
someone would get to know me as a person
before understanding or before knowing
my my sexuality my gender or so on
because at the end of the day my name is
Taz I you know I like sunsets I play Ice
Hockey I've done martial arts
um I like I like being out in nature
like there's so much more to me than
just my sex and my gender
um and my sexuality so I think it's far
more important to actually be able to
discuss and to talk to people and to to
find out who they are before fully
labeling them like I like with all due
respect guys I don't care what gender
any of you are I don't care who you go
to bed with funnily enough it doesn't
affect me
um when you don't go to the toilet I'm
not thinking what you are doing in there
I'm just going to toilet if you're not
thinking otherwise then that quite often
that's down to either you your
experience or the societal rhetoric
I don't think people care about what
people do in the bathrooms in my opinion
I think the bathroom thing is not is
really a non-issue I think people would
do whatever people want to do at the end
of the day but I think the problem is
when these things are put into
legislation
thereby forcing people to act a certain
way agreed that's my problem
if it's not put into legislation I don't
think people are walking around trying
to hate on transgender people and say ah
these are obviously they're always bad
people in society but the general
consensus is I think most people would
be okay letting other people live their
lives however they want to leave it
because there's been that much
difference or do you think that because
it will blow over eventually right I
understand the animosity right now the
problem I have with the legislation
aspect is that when we start accepting
things like this to be passed into
legislation then it doesn't knock on
effect other things would then is like
like what
couple of years ago where they forced
everyone to stay indoors and then when
it was all over we found out that it was
all
whatever it was but it's that kind of
rhetoric when we keep allowing these
things to be
you know it's hardly the same example I
think you know we've got the whole
conspiracy for his conspiracy theories
in regards to like what you just said
just then and lots of other things which
is government you know related but this
isn't a government thing this is what
are you doing what conspiracy theory is
like what are you talking about no your
colleagues just said in regards we had
to stay in our house for a certain
period of time and then we realized we
didn't have to do that anymore I mean
who's who's making you stay in your
house I don't get it I'm just going off
of the basics of what he said two years
ago the plan he's talking about David
yeah
David Ovid
I just think that's a little bit
different because that's like a
government thing and I'm all for that
conspiracy phrase I didn't take part in
none of them things there yeah still so
I I'm I'm fully against that that as
well but I'm just saying like I think
this is slightly different because this
is like trans people this is people so
this is not necessarily like a
government trying to push an agenda
legislation
only because it's trying to be inclusive
and be fair yeah that's hardly the same
as like Point uh that's the point
whatever yeah that is the point because
it's like you're forcing like especially
like I mean this is a Christian country
isn't it yeah so it's like you're
forcing P I mean I'm not saying I'm not
saying
yeah but the whole point and I'm from
the US so it's a Christian countries we
have Christian values and now we're
going to schools where now they're
putting in trans they're trans people
are coming or Sports in our bathrooms
and it's like you're forcing us to live
and act like it's normal when we don't
think it is and I hear that you know if
you're a religious individual and you've
been you know I'm going to call it
brainwashed into believe in these things
then I don't feel brain well I've been
I've been I was raised into Christianity
and I take Christianity very seriously
that's good that's good that's good I'm
a spiritual put Let me just finish I'm a
spiritual person yeah I'm a spiritual
person I believe in God I believe in all
of these things but with religion and
spirituality and different things that's
why you've got a lot of people that call
themselves spit they they believe in
spirituality or they're spiritual people
and you've got people that are religious
and they put themselves in these boxes
of different religions Hinduism Islam
Christianity Judaism and they all kind
of have the same thing but essentially
they've got these laws and these rules
that you need to abide by with
spirituality which is something that I
believe in we're free-spirited
individuals you know the main thing for
us is to to love and to evolve yeah
you guys have talked a lot let her go I
didn't say anything now you keep
interrupting her go ahead what I'm
trying to say is that you live in the UK
and we have laws right you like common
indecency you have to be fully clothed
right you couldn't just walk the streets
naked without no clothes that is a crime
so and you're talking about
um the different religious different
religions and different boxes that's
people's religions and cultures and
whatever they have going on but we have
laws here okay but I'm just saying that
you guys brought religion into it by
saying about this as a Christian country
not everyone in this country but the
point is if you choose Christianity but
the point is if you choose if you choose
to live in a Christian country there's
values that go along with it and so the
whole point is that you're coming into a
Christian country and saying that we
need to normalize things that we do not
agree with
yeah that's like that's like me like if
I if I went to um like I went to I
forgot where I was in the Middle East
but it was a couple years ago and they
they there are certain places where I
went in and I had to cover my hair I
don't personally believe that but
because I'm in their country like it's
disrespectful to force that on them yeah
and I think you know what like if you're
going into like a Muslim country and you
have to cover your hair like me
personally I would the type of person
that I am that I would try to respect
people's traditions and I would try to
respect these things you know when I go
to overseas I don't go out to people and
be like do you speak English you know I
mean like I try to but why should we
pass laws like
why do we pass laws trying to accept you
guys or like trans people for how they
are when they don't accept themselves
for how they are I think we do though I
think that we call ourselves transgender
and I think that that's a fair
terminology to call ourselves because we
don't but you can't accept Okay so if I
if I say I accept myself as I am and
then I get a nose job a boob job a BBL
then you would say no you don't but
if I said I accept myself as I am and
then I get a bit of the BBL a boob job
Botox all this done to myself then
I wouldn't accept the way that I was
born
but but you guys are trans people in
general will will change their hormones
they'll get surgeries they'll do all
this stuff and then say accept me as I
am but you're not even accepting
yourself as who you are no okay so to
cut you yeah I think what what we've
just discussed here as transgender
individuals is that we've gone through
difficulties in our own life where we
didn't accept who we was we didn't
accept ourselves for who he was in the
body that we was assigned yeah now
whether people want to call it nature on
her child they must have gone through
some messed up thing in their childhood
to make them do whatever there's like
whatever type of psychological aspect
people want to look at it is up to them
but essentially like I think that if
people are gonna go down the route of
but I'm just saying the physical route
you can't accept your physical body if
you if you're but they do once you once
so once you so if I talk for myself yeah
so I didn't accept myself previously
like I didn't like myself I tried I
really did honestly I I tried and we we
could say that's like a mental switch
but once it becomes physical and you're
doing the surgeries you you can't like
like just logically you cannot say I
accepted myself as I am if you were born
one way and then you got surgeries to be
another exactly that's because you
didn't accept yourself and I'm not
saying that's a horrible thing I'm not
saying like do as you wish right but it
would be the same way like if I if I got
a big huge boob job and I said I
accepted myself as as I am no I didn't
because I went and got the surgery
you could compare it to gaining a lot of
weight and then losing the weights
no because you're not born obese like
you weren't happy with the weights so
you lost it and that's a good thing no
but but you're not born that way like
like if anything's kind of saying like
you can't evolve so that basically that
is what you're saying is that goes
against my beliefs as humans that we're
supposed to evolve so to say that you're
not born a certain way means that
whatever happens in your life I think
God makes you I mean this is a bit more
religious but I think God makes you a
certain way like I think exactly no but
I I no I I think I think God gives you I
think God gives you a gender and I think
the genders come from God so I don't
think God makes mistakes
I've made a mistake no I mean but it is
because in a way like the surgery is
playing God because it's like you're
trying to you pick your gender and Only
God that's exactly what it is that's
literally what it is and and I think
that you know like if you're gonna if
you're gonna be able to pick your gender
if science has evolved to the point
where people can say you know what I
don't feel comfortable as I am
and I want to change I want to put
myself through physical distress I want
to put myself potentially in a firing
aim of a lot of people's negative
opinions but guess what it's going to
make me happy it's going to make me feel
good about myself so you know what I'm
gonna do it I think right now but I
think that kind of speaks to the culture
it's like a me me culture instead of
it's like what makes me happy instead of
what makes what's good for families
which is what it used to be a hundred
years ago I'm not saying it's wrong or
it's right I'm saying the difference
like that this is this is when I look at
the culture nowadays it's all about me
and it has to where it used to be I
would I think it's better when it's
about family yeah right like I think a
hundred years ago it was about what's
best for the family can I just respond
my family does not suffered can I just
say yeah I'm not talking about you I'm
not talking about you guys personally
but you can't reproduce okay let me just
talk about models can I just talk about
can we adopt all of the kids that all
the heterosexuals don't look after all
yes there's people so can I just say yes
say for example like good luck good luck
and then there's a long list anyways
that's that's the other thing it's like
this really false narrative with
adoption like there's all these kids
that people don't want the issue is they
that people that shouldn't be parents
give them up later they're older but
when it comes to babies there's like a
wait list it's tough to get a baby
that's true it's awesome you have to you
have to go through a very vigorous
training for assessment yeah you have to
be you have to be like this whole
um they do DBS checks on you they do you
know they visit your home they do random
visits it's hard no my parents have done
it both ways they've adopted and they've
given up so I've been on both sides it's
it's different than people think
um but sorry what were you saying man
honestly I forgot so you have to just
come back to me you need to Corral us
into an actual topic instead of us
rambling so so
um my next question is oh yeah go ahead
go ahead okay so um I have a question if
if our bones are dug up two thousand
years from now what gender would you be
identified with and if the answer is
binary
why should we make laws to accommodate
you cannot accurately
it's not accurate 100 of the time
there's like a 30 40 deviance already
okay
male and female have different
um pelvic structures because that's
right that's right okay it's not right
it's not right actually Google and do
some research onto this because you're
just completely wrong and should read
some books why is he wrong because you
can't always tell that easily there are
women with smaller hips
and you're arguing for exceptions rather
no this is not an exception I know okay
so what I'm going to say to you you can
tell me if I can answer your question
yeah it's not a Surefire thing honestly
yeah like if you're if your bones are
dug up
you're probably going to be classified
by your gender but in my opinion yeah
all that matters is the quality of life
when you're here yeah there's people
that are miserable yeah there's people
that kill themselves they're depressed
they don't want to live their truth
there's people like yourself they're not
scared to make their opinions knowing
how much they're gonna be hated you know
I think people need to be celebrated
people that live their truth no matter
how much they're going to be knocked and
torn down they need to be celebrated
because it's not easy and when I die
when I'm dead I'm gonna well I don't
know what happens but let's say there's
an afterlife I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna say you know what I've done my
best here on Earth
monologues what he's asking you're not
answering his questions
the reality is
there is a There is almost like a facade
behind this whole transgender thing
changing your gender with surgeries
doesn't necessarily guarantee you a
better life in fact if you look at the
statistics more people suffer after
surgeries than before so it's not like
you they make it seem like when you
change your gender then you
automatically accept yourself and then
you're going to be comfortable with your
skin in fact you actually especially for
the male to female transition you you
probably have a worse life
um expectancy afterwards
I honestly haven't done any research
about transgender people all I all I
have is my own personal experiences I
can't even say I've got many uh any
friends yeah
um that are transgender actually yeah so
like honestly all I can go on is my own
personal experience but you know I just
think that quality of life is so
important we're only here for a certain
amount of time and I just think it's
really important for everyone to just be
happy in whatever way that means
obviously you can't be like you know
doing like killing people just because
it makes you happy but I think changing
your body and your physique things that
are personal to yourself I don't think
why it should be seen as such a big
problem some people are going to regret
it right what if I want to be black what
if should I do that it makes me happy I
should pay I mean white people sometimes
they go on you know sometimes Sun cream
I'm asking me should I do that if it
makes up to you yes go ahead but I can I
just answer your question so when I die
and my bones are like in the ground and
whatnot I know that I'm gonna be my
bones are gonna come come out as a woman
because I identify as a woman and a
woman only it's not how it works I don't
identify as anything else that's my
answer I'm the only one that has ever
read into this is clear there isn't a
certain amount of deviants
it's pretty straightforward you know
there's like a pelvic difference between
a man that isn't consistent and look you
can look it up making assumptions it's
the fact that you're going off on
exceptions when no this is literally
it's like 100 deviance is not an
exception what's the majority 60 okay no
no that that 30. that's thirty percent
of men
that's not true thank you go ahead she
you've talked a lot let her talk no
one's much as these guys
I don't know I don't know where to go
from like you know but um
I had one question
um it was for Taz so
um when you mentioned how um so you
mentioned you all miss them has being
transgendered like is it like a
challenge for you like to be Muslim and
transgender at the same time it's not a
challenge for me not
so like say for example so
um do you visit like the mosque like I
go to an inclusive Moscow I'll just pray
at home okay fine
um so like you don't feel any sort of
you know like going into a mosque any
type of discomfort like if if no I
decided to go to a mosque I like I
wouldn't go to the Masjid that I went to
when I was younger
but partly I didn't feel comfortable in
that Masjid anyway because I was in the
women's section and I felt like I was
being disrespectful to to to the CIS
women in there knowing that I like and
this was before I even like had the term
for it like I just didn't feel
comfortable I feel like I was being
disrespectful to them was it like in
your like your very
um very much I am a man and I just feel
disrespectful by even being around all
these women it's not even that I am a
man it's just that I am not holy who and
what they are
okay like I feel like if if you take it
from the point of view you heard that
for example
the women women who cover their hair are
mustard quite often have decided that
that is for them yeah right the hijab or
the niklab is for them yeah
they will only take off the hijab on the
club if they are around male family
members of the immediate family yeah
right
now I don't feel holy female I don't
feel holy male
I felt like I was being disrespectful
because I was seeing hair that was not
meant for me not meant for my eyes
yeah
only meant for the eyes of sisters or
their immediate male family members but
do you not think that you know obviously
if God Made You
made you female
does like because I don't think
personally like speaking I don't think
God makes any mistakes and if everything
God makes mistakes either I fully agree
with that
I believe in like with spirituality I
sometimes I believe in like you know
past lives past life Karma also believe
in you know lessons that we had us our
spirit has to go through and soul
lessons and things like that so
sometimes I wonder to myself you know
why you know I I always like I said he
was a boy
I always knew I was a little boy
so sometimes as an adult now I think to
myself what type of past life Karma am I
paying off while I was born in a female
body this time you know so we all
believe in different things you know I
actually have a question that kind of
goes off of that a little bit you always
believed you're a boy do you think that
social media can ever brainwash kids
into thinking that they're trans yep yep
I think social media is extremely
powerful and I think that I can
brainwash anyone to do a lot of things
maybe so you would agree yeah what about
you sure I think yeah occultist
attitudes can exist anywhere I don't
know if transgender people are the
biggest issue but it can happen I can
see I can imagine it happening okay what
do you think
I feel like anyone like anyone anyone
vulnerably vulnerable enough to anything
can be swayed to anything I think social
media especially for young people can
can it's where young people to do a lot
like there's there's a like I remember
the happy slapping generation of our
time yeah that says oh like you've got
kids out there that you know they were
raised right they know they're not
supposed to put their hands on anyone
they know that they're supposed to you
know do this be right for each other you
know you've got your Ten Commandments
this Christian country and you were
taught them from Young and but then
suddenly they've got a camera phone in
there out here slapping God knows who on
the bus or like walking past some random
unknown person slapping them social
media can can cause so many things it
can tell someone you know it can it can
sway someone or make someone think that
something is okay when it's not most
definitely okay most definitely so this
was that we all agreed yeah do you guys
think the trans movement is
indoctrinating our youth no
no I just think you're spreading
awareness and I think it's just making
it more you know it's good to talk about
why do we need to spread awareness like
why do kids need to know about this
stuff you know to stop Prejudice I think
leave the kids out of it and maybe focus
on the teenagers instead yeah the
teenagers you know if those kids are
just so young there's mines are sponges
anything they they could not they could
be raised as like you know their
particular genders right and then they
have a talk at school like you know how
we had the sex talk at school and then
they had the trans talk right which
could confuse the kids and make them
feel like there's something when they're
not if that makes sense I don't think
it's necessary assuming like 13 and
above or yeah so teenage years I just
think it should come to I think I would
say 18.
um do you not think that um I know that
for an example so my little brother he's
11 and in his school they're promoting
it I say promoting because they are
pushing it onto children
and my parents didn't even know that it
was happening so when he came home with
this ideology and this other like he's
talking about things we've never even
imagined him to be talking about it's
like but he never even thought he was
going to be a girl or he wanted to be a
girl anyway but he's bringing it up when
it's he I think it should only be a
thing where it's like okay
18 like past 18 we stopped you know
spreading awareness whatever you say
past 18 but the the age restriction on
Facebook is like 14 so and they can end
up seeing stuff on Facebook yeah
I mean yeah yeah you can do it I think I
don't think we need to tell them at all
I think it should be something you
should Discover it because if you truly
are it then you will Discover it there
is no need for it to be promoted because
if you're promoting
it's like a you know what can I say
something I feel like we need to create
awareness you guys are right about
awareness because till today I did not
know as much as I know now about the
trans movement and just transgender
people in general like it's not
something that is discussed in like
secondary school or college or it's just
kind of pushed past and it comes up in
the news every now and then but it's not
something that we actually understand
and know about if that makes sense where
would you two draw the line between some
awareness and what is like promotion
what is okay and what is like too much
too much is basically handing out forms
saying would you like to trans just
transition from being a man to a woman
that is a bit too much I think awareness
is just saying hey these kind of people
exist yeah they're in our world yeah
this is how they some of them might go
through certain situations that might be
a very emotional Journey for them but
this is what they what is I think that's
perfect I think I think that's a
conversation for the parents if they
want to have it I think no institution
should be pushing that at all but you
know what you know what I think would
also be good in school life skills yeah
money management there's a lot of things
that the curriculum that we don't agree
with like in our age group as well 34
year olds or whatever and older our
curriculum is like in you know with
religious studies history actually
history history I actually think that's
all that a certain narrative that has
been pushed for us you know if it's more
of a lack of like things your your
parents used to teach you but now it's
like the average kid spends 30 minutes a
day with their parents so your parents
used to I mean we have a whole
generation of people that don't know how
to do anything
really you know seriously like what
percent of guys can like build a house
what percent of women have a cookbook I
can cook I can serve I know we're not
talking about you we're talking about in
general but I think we should promote
those things I mean when I was at school
they still did biomack instead like yeah
and I'm not I'm not saying that's a bad
thing like finally could promote it in
school but my whole point I think with
the Trans stuff like I just think that's
if the parents want to talk to their
kids about that that's something for the
parents but not because some parents
start to cut you but some parents yeah
really don't give their kids knowledge
like some parents they don't do that
that's their right yeah but look we we
should well why if I grew up in a
Christian or Catholic household or
Muslim household like why should we be
forced to learn about something because
there's a real world outside your house
and there's a lot of things that we can
learn about but we don't have to learn
about everything because it's a big
thing so so but now it's like now you're
saying you should raise your kids the
way that I think you should race
is what I'm saying is that there's
certain things yeah look not every
family is the Brady Bunch not every
parent is gold star and gives all that
you know their children all the
information there are some parents that
neglect their kids don't give the kids
but you're acting like trans like not
teaching them trans is somehow
neglecting them look I was never I was
never taught that that's not so that's
not what I'm saying let me rephrase what
I'm trying to say is in as a whole you
do have some parents that neglect their
children from you know uh knowledge yeah
knowledge that's out here in the world
that they that will prepare them for
when it comes to trans wouldn't you
agree that there's nothing wrong with a
parent not teaching them no no if a
parent doesn't want to then that's fine
but it will just make their child
ignorant and then it will make their
child go out into the world the
institutions should not push this I
think they should push it because it's
something that is going on in the world
okay so that then that goes back to
indoctrinating the kids like this is
where you have to understand this is
where the conservatives I think it
should come in right but I don't think
it should be pushed I think it should be
just that's pushing it on the kids
because I'm just going to tell you where
we're coming from because a lot of times
the trans people will say we're not
pushing it on the kids but if I'm gonna
if I'm in a Christian or conservative or
Muslim household like we don't agree
with that like we think that's wrong
yeah and we don't think we should have
to teach our kids about that we want to
keep the kids innocent 100 okay but and
that doesn't take away the innocence by
giving someone knowledge I would I would
say it does I would say it's very
confusing it doesn't it doesn't it's
very confusing I have I have younger
siblings right I'm trying to explain to
them that you can be a woman I have
younger brothers right you can be a
woman it'd be very confusing about how
what how do you do that how does that
work what do you take do they feed you
drugs
you can talk about that because you know
there's lots of things that
overcomplicate things yeah it's just
it's like it's like you're happy to talk
about something but how did you explain
to your child he's asking that question
how do you explain well you go to a
doctor you pay a certain amount of money
and then you get your genitalia you
don't eat it look pretty much all you do
is say look sometimes I've done it I've
got good kids I've got good kids I've
got younger cousins I've got nieces and
nephews yeah and they obviously know me
they know so it's a little bit maybe
biased to use myself an example because
they could obviously see and be like
okay yeah it makes sense but you know
for kids that don't have the example
right in front of them it's really
simple you just say you know this person
didn't feel comfortable being a boy and
they wanted to be a girl kids are so
understanding they're not like adults
they're so they're so understanding they
might pick on other kids but you know at
the end of the day it's all just for fun
this is where we're coming from though
when we're saying it's indoctrinating
the children because again you like the
way you feel like you feel like this
knowledge should be spread so you think
that schools should teach it where the
Christians in the school should teach
you earlier
all I'm saying is I don't I'm not
against it being taught in schools I'm
not for it but I don't see why it's an
issue for it to be possible
I would say it's an issue because again
it's normalizing something that we don't
want to be normalized because we don't
agree with that and also he made a point
he made a point he said
um
he said um
there are some parents that don't give
their children knowledge and that's a
very good point so if their parents that
that exist like that I don't give their
children knowledge how is giving them
trans knowledge going to help their
situation anyways I think you know more
confusing no I think all it does is it
just it just gives people yeah an option
an opportunity sorry to deal with these
type of situations appropriately when
they're confronted with it but if the
person already missed out on all the
knowledge that's important to be a good
person in the first place how is having
trust you know it's going to be any
better in making them whoever you want
it's not about being a good person
because someone can still have all of
the knowledge about what a transgender
person is what it means and still and
still be disrespectful still think it's
rubbish still thinking so having the
knowledge on the subject it doesn't make
make you a good or bad person but
knowledge is always beneficial there's
nothing wrong with having knowledge okay
so should we should we should children
have knowledge on how to build warheads
and how to build because that's a
negative thing that's a that's not
exactly
think that the transgender ideology is
detrimental to their children and how
they want them to be raised that's the
point I think you know when we're
talking about human beings and what
human beings are are doing with
themselves in terms of how they feel
about themselves sexuality uh whether
they like to marry inside of their
religion outside of their religion
you've got to think about all of the
people that have had to face
difficulties marrying outside of their
religion and it's all a form of
prejudice and this is what I'm trying to
say when I use race in these things as
an example I understand it's a social
construct opposed to like a physical
thing but it's still prejudice wouldn't
you say your Prejudice prejudice against
religious people because you think we're
brainwashed no no like that's the thing
the left does the same exact thing they
just do it to the conservatives and the
religious people say something yeah you
can't wait can I just answer your thing
one second put a pin on it I'm not
prejudiced I used to be religious yeah
um I used to I used to classify myself
as Christian I went to Christian church
with my Jamaican grandparents and I was
so for so long searching for a purpose
searching for a higher purpose because I
knew that there was more to this life
than just me and my human form
but in my in my search for black history
um Christianity just didn't black
history and Christianity doesn't match
yeah there's conflict
and so that's the reason why I'm not a
Christian because uh as black people and
that's our Mysteries but you know
identify as mixtures but more so black
than anything else
um we we we these these type of things
you know like in terms of like
Christianity and Islam has been put upon
us like the Christianity started in
Africa though yeah uh it didn't bro I'm
from Nigeria Christian style in Africa I
started in Utopia
the religions that in Africa predate
Christianity and pre-date Islam yeah but
it started in Africa
it may have been there but Africa's a
continent that's been around for
obviously a very long time a little fast
question
if we're making the basis of religion
our argument are you against schools
teaching science because that directly
contradicts religion obviously not right
no one wants to hear us again science
complementary Evolution science again
yeah
there's only idiots that argue that
science and like it's the reality is
science actually most of the things that
are proven in science if you look in the
Bible it's almost the same thing you
just they just argue on semantics
directly contradicts Evolution even even
if I don't know you know honestly I
think the parents have the right to have
their kids have whatever knowledge they
want I think the parents will always
have the best interest of the child at
heart if you're good do I want to feel
good whatever I would say there is there
is nobody that has a more incentive for
the kid to turn out good than the
parents even shitty parents want their
kid to turn out good even even shitty
parents it's more like this
but but the parents are always going to
do more for the kid than a stranger so
you're saying Oh The Strangers which is
the school is going to do better knows
best for my kid when every kid is
different and no person is more info
information on the children than the
parents like I'll give you an example
like one thing they always push is sex
ed in schools right and I've always
always said the anti-sex that I think
it's weird I think it's gross I don't
know why they're talking about that to
kids but and the reason I say that is
because different kids need that
conversation at different points like I
have I can think of two two friends I
had growing up one one would have needed
that conversation at like 12 you know
what I mean and the other was so
innocent like she would she wouldn't
even need it till 20. and so but the the
parents always have the most information
and know their kid the best yeah
so you know maybe the parent would think
that one kid would need to know the
trans stuff the evolution whatever it is
but I think at the end of the day the
parents have a right to pick what
information their kids get and I don't
think that's sick curriculum I don't
know
you can homeschool your kids again I
think the parents have the right to
raise their kids how they want I don't
think the state had like should have
more power on raising the kids than the
parents I think in this day and age as
well I think
um lgbtq and like transgender like it is
so like it will come up anyway in the
household or between the parent and the
child it doesn't need to be promoted in
school because it is so easy for a
parent to take their child out take them
outside and the child will just
naturally be confused they'll be curious
and there will be there are people at
different stages within the
transitioning journey and the child
might be like oh well Dad
um you know why is a man wearing a skirt
or you know why why is he wearing a wig
the child will ask the parent and then
it's the parent's job to then see if the
child is Young or young enough or old
enough to you know know like they need
to know about it or not like it's not it
doesn't need to be promoted in schools I
think it's ridiculous I guess so it's
the word of the word promotion it's the
word promotion because it is not a
promotion because
what we're doing now promotion because
some people would care no I would say I
would say because you choose to to watch
my Channel or you don't but with the
school they don't get a choice so so if
the teachers are talking about trans I
would say the same thing with with gay I
would say the same thing with anything
that you know religious people or a
certain group might disagree with if if
the if they are talking about it then
there is no choice and you know what
that's fine because there's a lot of
things in schools that you don't want to
learn about that's why when you get to a
certain point in your school time you
get to pick subjects but sometimes
no because why is that not it because
it's the same thing as learning as
learning sex sexual education in school
because it all leads to sex and yeah you
know the child is too young to know
anything about it okay
sex out of schools why get get rid of
the stack side
get rid of all of it like I don't wanna
I don't wanna I don't want the trans
stuff
because we need that in schools
I disagree with that because but see the
issue is we look at outcomes like it's
always like the idea of it but never
outcomes because I at one point I used
to think maybe sex ed would be a good
thing but but the thing is people are
more promiscuous after sex had than
before because it was implemented in
around the 70s
we could look at body count we could
look at abortions we could like again
people are more promiscuous now than
they were 50 years ago
but the thing is but the thing is like
about kids getting pregnant it's just
nonsense it's like it's like it's
General now like it's very common and it
shouldn't be common because it's a very
sacred thing I think it's so sacred I
think the things that's so good it's
just I just think it just should
wouldn't be accessible like that well I
don't know that these kids are the
internet they're going to find out
their parents and ask their parents
about it and their parents will word it
in a way that isn't going to corrupt
them I'll be honest they probably won't
go to their parents they'll go to their
mates I went to my parents well and and
the parents the parents can choose if
they have cell phones or not yeah the
parents could I I know I have I have a
whole no I I know people that do it
without it I know most people will but
at the end of the day the power should
be with the parents not the school I
think I think when it comes to to
schools schools should teach things like
Body Language they should teach things
like how to create boundaries for
yourself consent
no I don't think
that's so subjective no but it's about
understanding for example yeah
English also we do right science now
instead of learning sex ed I would fall
rather my kids learn what it is like in
a group environment to see different
body languages and how this person is
not happy right now why are they not
happy this person is Happy why could
they be happy what is it that this
person and this person have a difference
right now and how are they viewing the
situation I think things like that would
be far more beneficial than how to put a
condom on it's not that I don't it's not
that I don't agree with you I agree with
you 100 but when from my experiences
learning sex ed I was scared to even get
myself into that position of being
promiscuous because of all the STDs of
getting pregnant disappointing my
parents all those things because those
pictures that they showed us yeah very
graphic and made me feel like okay cool
maybe I'm not going to mess around and
do things and just be free and whatnot
no and I I think there could be
hypothetical benefits but again I just
think again it should be the parents
picking that out the state yeah so I
don't have a problem with showing that
to your kids but it's kind of like
consent forms should go around in the
schools like they should take them home
and let them let the parents read the
form if they want their children to
learn about sex ed and it's like I don't
even want that I don't want my kids
being around kids that had sex then so
that's gonna be a struggle even even
like let's say you get all these creeps
you have these grown-ass adults talking
to these kids about sex we got a video
so it wasn't like people talking it was
literally just a video friends teachers
at my school I even think it's weird I
went to a Catholic school I don't even
think they should do like abstinence
talks I think it's weird I think go to
your parents what's Wilson absence like
oh stopping not having sex yeah it's
like um it's don't have sex basically
but it's like an inspirational way did
you not celibacy or something yeah yeah
it's like they come in and they say like
don't have sex and I do go to a
religious Primary School and I remember
that so we had a Jehovah's Witness and
they could opt out of a bunch of things
I'm sure if you're super desperate for
your kid to not do things you can talk
to the teachers and ask them but I if
you really want to keep them away from
other kids that are learning this too
that's going to be hard unless you
homeschool them I don't know I mean
that's a lot a lot of conservatives are
going yeah I mean because you can
totally do that that's fine yeah that's
fine probably the best bet if you have a
problem with things like that it's
probably best to just homeschool yeah
you can teach your kid more yeah taxes
bills they can learn way more way more
than anything
they should have done taxes in PSAT for
sure 100 yeah and pensions because
actually it's long yeah man also I
looked into the I Googled the
differences in the pelvic bone of male
and female and I've been scrolling for
days I'm not about pelvic bones it's
about the bones that was my argument but
I haven't seen any argument that
supports what you said everything what
did I say I said the feeling what did I
say I don't know what you're saying I'll
tell you what I said I don't know what I
said that guy that wrote Whatever I said
no we actually we had a guy Super Chat
to this but he I actually know who it is
he's the author of the history of sex so
he's written like books on this stuff
um I'll find it in a second but I'm
gonna Read Super chats um and then I'll
ask one more question then we'll close
out the show just to give you guys
timeline
um let me go down uh what were you
saying I'm sorry King did I cut you off
oh yeah I was just saying like I I glued
it and literally what I said was the
female pelvic bone is designed
differently from the male perfect bone
because the female pelvic bone has to
expand during childbirth now I know
there are women that might not be able
to give birth but that doesn't change
the fact that they are designed for it
we don't know so it's it's not just
about the pelvic bone it's about it's
very difficult when you're Digging Up
Bones if you're an actual archaeologist
right there's a certain amount of bones
that you just can't tell that there are
boys if there are girls or if they're an
adult you're moving the goal post the
goal post to argue no no no I'm talking
about he's just talking about the bones
I'm just saying I'm just saying if you
were to dig up bones of people and
obviously you could see the pelvic you
would know who is a male and who's a
female I'm saying unfortunately it's not
as easy as that it would be great if it
was to be honest I mean I wouldn't have
anything to argue against Dr Dr David
Baker flower dress you apparently aren't
a theologian either majority of
Christian denominations do not interpret
Genesis literally stop straw Manning
millions of people uh with ideas of
fundamentalist minorities I'm Gib and
dishonest Bibi if anything uh sex ed
should be uh RP empty hands with Grace
as a person who is confused as a child I
can tell them this stop living with the
lust of the Flesh and seek Jesus in
spirit and in truth to be free
one-to-one relationship with God read
the gospel this was this was the guy I
was telling you about he he wrote a book
on like the history of sex the history
of the Universe I interviewed this dude
um flower dress you aren't an
archaeologist archaeologist either a
complete undamaged pelvis identifies sex
with a high accuracy where there is
damaged tooth proteins still identify
sex on a binary and never what the
person identified as which is the damn
point puffy uh vegans Vegas people do
drugs we should teach kids how to use
them black a phoenix treat people like
you want to be treated I don't call
people straight phobic or say you're
Brainwashed the term CIS also came from
a pedo dragon stallion1001 dress you
don't know squat pelvic
male narrower heart-shaped female open
circular uh
read this kayak Notch male narrower
female there are six different bones
that archaeologists use to identify the
sex 90 Frito pie Pale Lady close your
lips God doesn't give cancer we humans
have made cancer food and materials it's
sad but God has nothing to do with it
Doug MPA what Trans on the couch would
be okay with being drafted Ice Man clown
world
BB easier to put on a dress than to go
to the gym climb that male hierarchy
which is brutal and become a teacher
become a teacher to get around kids
Black Phoenix
oh wait I read this one already okay let
me refresh it really quick before uh
I'm gonna ask one more question uh Pearl
uh woman is
per a pale woman is a snake early
fathers of of science acknowledge God as
an authority over science you're just a
basic woman like any woman work at
McDonald's okay
um sorry
um
I'm a vegetarian
um okay so I'm gonna ask one last
question which is do you guys think God
intended there to be two genders yes yes
my other end to sex people
I don't know okay so like religious
arguments are a bit lost on me I'm not
like I went to a religious Primary
School okay I'm not like hateful of
religious people
it's just I'm not what I base my
arguments from because if God exists
he's done a lot of heinous so I
don't know man
I don't know man I think just like I
believe in the devil too just so you
know yeah but I just see all the kids
that suffer babies born with cancer and
it's just like there's a God that
exists yeah I mean nice I mean we
believe in like the devil too so that's
kind of how we would do you think the
devil does it
fair enough
so your question yeah God made two
genders
it's techy because yes but like what my
definition of gender and your definition
of gender is not the same so when I
answer your question is yes it's not the
same yes that you say because
automatically I view gender differently
to you so I I class trans men
as men even though they've transitioned
into men so they still fit the category
of uh one of the other gender yeah and
same for trans women so yes there's two
genders and there's still two genders
however some of those people and some of
those genders are transgenders
okay what about you
um
I believe God made me exactly as I am
like my not not you just like how many
genders
I don't believe it's the binary okay
likes but a spokesperson cannot speak
for good that God made me as I am so no
I don't agree
okay so how many genders did he make
I can't put a name on it unlimited I
could I don't know okay what I know is
that it's not not two not two okay
um okay guys I'm getting so hot so hey
I don't okay I'm
when I came to the UK everyone said you
don't need air conditioning you don't
need it oh it's not what you do it's
sticky
it's not that hot here and the last two
summers I have been gaslit I appreciate
you for being honest
but everyone lied to me when I came here
they said it's not that bad and it is it
is that bad um but thank you guys for
coming you know I know guys keep it at
certain points but I do I do hope you
guys come back I think this was a fun
combo
um so um final thoughts you know
anything you want to speak your piece on
now is the time starting here and then
go around
uh regardless I just feel like you
should approach people with love and
compassion and consideration I feel like
you should literally just treat each
other as you want to be treated and you
know we'll figure out the rest
as it happens
any social media you want to plug follow
me no okay go ahead
well I'm not a biologist and I am not an
archaeologist but um I am allowed to
have my opinion are you a theologian no
neither is anyone here just pointing
that out but um you know
um I think it doesn't hurt to just be a
little bit more kind to each other and I
think that goes for both sides of things
I think that I really want us to meet
like in the middle and make a compromise
and make things work as things are we
have laws in place if we want to
campaign to change them it's better to
do it in a way that's productive
um
I think that Pearl you have
um you have good things to fight for and
I think that you've done a great job
putting this panel together I think that
you got two transgender people here is
amazing
um that you didn't just you know we have
this conversation about transgender
people and they're not even in the room
so I think it's great that you get in
that space yeah I'm trying to do more
panels where the things we talk about
here yeah no I think you deserve a lot
of kudos for that because I I can't say
I've seen that a whole lot from other
people that are in your space so yeah I
know I'll tell my opinions to anyone
respectfully respectfully you know I
don't even disagree with a lot of your
opinions it's just like I would like to
see you succeed it's just you know as I
suggest the ways to which you could
succeed you're not keen on but that's
okay I just I can't do it I can't bend
my morals I can't bend the way I you
know what do you call these would you
call these guys she
in a personal relationship I'm gonna be
polite but if if they want to police my
Twitter that's where I I am a tweeter
that's where I draw the line I like
being unhinged on Discord so if you like
being unhinged on Twitter I get it it's
funny it's my favorite thing I want to
be on the internet I get it I like to
think I'm I'm hinged no you're not but I
just think I think you yeah I think
go ahead
thanks for having me yeah I mean I think
I've pretty much said anything about
it's been a pleasure to be on the show
hopefully of my opinions I've kind of
shared some awareness in in some regard
you know and like I said before I do
believe in
um our human evolution you know is the
main thing and also to spread love to
accept everyone for who they are no I
mean and I just think that there's not
there's much bigger fish to fry than
worrying about how someone feels
comfortable in their own skin and as
long as it's not kind of stepping on
anyone's toes which I guess sometimes it
is
um in terms of like what we was mainly
speaking about in regards to sport
unless there's gonna be specific
leagues and I think this will happen
over time when there's more uh more of a
bigger community of transgender people
but for right now I think we're just
trying to fit in you know where we can
you know I mean and I think over time
there will be more room for transgender
people like there has been for gay and
lesbian people
and women trying to work and all the
other races that I've tried to to get up
here you know Prejudice as a whole you
know it takes time for a movement well
if you know I have a different view on
the women working thing but you know
maybe that's a different show
um I think just do what you want as long
as it doesn't harm other people
um don't impose your personal beliefs on
other people
um I personally I'm a fax over feelings
kind of person I like black and white I
don't like gray areas I just think that
when things get confusing
it just leads to a big fat mess so I
just think
just do what you want just don't be
hurting anyone that's it
so my final thoughts are I feel like
maybe leave the babies out of it leave
the kids out of it they shouldn't be
forced upon to learn something that is
just too
much of a conversation to have if that
makes sense
um
yeah but I agree everyone should be a
little bit nicer to each other we should
spread the love and we should accept
people for who they are
well I thought this was a nice everyone
was nice tonight right okay
send donations for a king camera
okay but my final thought today is
um I actually agree with a lot of things
that we said here in the terms of people
should be allowed to live their lives
however they want to live it I think
people shouldn't be treated or
mistreated just because of however they
choose to live their lives but that
being said I think that
yes transgenderism and the whole concept
around it should be publicized as long
as it's publicized as abnormal and not
publicized as being a normal thing
that's that's just that's what I think
because I think the information needs to
be out there but I think it's being
pushed
with an agenda so it it actually the way
it's being done now actually hurts
transgender people
so I don't think it helps anyone in any
regard I think it should be pushed like
people should understand the realities
of it because like I said there are many
people that go through searches and they
don't even realize their the life of
hurts that they're going to be getting
into and that's just because of
the lack of information but yeah that's
my final thought
okay guys
um thank you all for coming
um I you know I did a panel with Vice on
on trans stuff uh with and this was a
launch stuff this was a lot nicer I'll
tell you the energy is a lot more
pleasant
um oh yeah you said that was that you
know it's crazy that was like four hours
but they added it down to like 45
minutes they cut you off so much and
they were just like you could tell the
edits were as well and you're like oh my
gosh they cut out they cut out so many
points but it's okay you know they're
bankrupt now so I think it's karma
Adam said okay Cinderella you criticized
Pearl's tone yet you speak in pure
condescension at Doug MPA I'm sorry
they're going for you girl in the dress
uh Pearl is more successful than you'll
ever be she doesn't need your opinions
or your support keep them to yourself
shut your mouth okay guys I picked up I
think that's all I'm sorry sorry I'm
Julia you know
um some people say I shouldn't but I I
read the super chats you know anyways
guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and sign up to
our Google form we're going to be doing
events in London former show guests are
gonna come we're gonna rent out a nice
little bar everyone's gonna hang out
have a good time have some drinks so if
you want to come meet the your favorite
show guest your favorite co-hosts your
favorite you know people the The
Producers everyone sign up for our
Google form because you will be notified
when we do these events in London and
the US hopefully when I'm there like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk see you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village podcast it's
your boy The Fresh Prince
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you like not just
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do going out
having fun get out okay okay then then
get out then get out faster Esther then
get out I'm not here to get canceled
today most men want a woman that has
some degree of femininity where they
feel like they're taking care of taking
care of and lady like I'm submissive and
you'll be surprise because I will say
what I want to say now and I'll say what
I want to say with my mind but my
demeanor doesn't change and I'm gonna
look down on him because at the end of
the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened in
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I would feel so bad asking a
guy to buy like a three thousand dollar
bag
you he foreign
[Music]